I think... I think Nimi written.
Thank you!
I was watching earlier.
I was watching you play crossword and pokédoku and... Yeah.
Thank you!
I hope you had fun!
I hope you had fun being big-brained.
Hello!
Oh, I need my intro.
Hello everybody!
My name is Meidominto.
And I'm playing Oblivion Elder Scrolls ever!
First time!
It's my first ever!
Elder Scrolls game!
So... Yeah!
Small Minto.
Yeah, today I'm Chibi Minto because...
I thought maybe... the game would run better.
If I'm... If I'm Chibi Minto.
I love you!
Yeah, so... Um...
Um... I'm Chibi Minto.
And... Um...
I think it'll be okay, though.
I think it'll be okay.
The game only started to kind of...
poop itself after a little while of me playing.
Hehehehe...
I...
I'm excited to...
Guys!
I'm kinda... I'm kinda concerned.
Do I have a bounty on my head for breaking the law or...
Um... Wait, that's?
Oh.
All I did was borrow a horse.
Like, in-game.
Yeah, of course, in-game.
What do you think I'm doing, huh?
I only borrowed a horse.
And... it's not my fault that guy fell... tripped and fell on my sword.
Wait, I don't have a sword.
On my arrows?
Did you go get your yogurt?
I went to the yogurt place.
So, after Devil May Cry, I said, I'm gonna go get yogurt.
That was my motivation.
I was like, okay, I beat Devil May Cry, I'm gonna go get yogurt.
And I drove.
I went there.
It's 30 minutes there, 30 minutes back.
So, I was like, I'm gonna go get yogurt.
It's a new yogurt place.
And I was like, I'm really in there.
I love yogurt.
So, I always wanna get some yogurt.
I always wanna try a yogurt place.
And I went.
And I got there.
And I walked in.
And it said, orders closed 10 minutes ago.
So, they weren't closed.
But they were not taking any more orders.
So, honestly, how could I have known that?
Which is even...
Like, it's one thing...
It would be one thing if I, like, didn't check the times.
And they were closed.
And I was like, oh shoot, that's my fault.
I should've...
I should've checked the times that they were closed.
But no.
Instead, they closed their orders a whole hour.
A whole hour before they closed.
I was like, come on, man.
Come on, man.
So, I haven't been back.
Yeah, I felt so scammed.
Cause I was like, I drove a whole half hour.
I've wasted a whole hour of my afterlife.
Going to try and get yogurt.
I just wanted yogurt.
I wanted specialty yogurt.
Oh, well.
I would say live and learn, but I'm dead.
So, I don't learn nothing.
I don't learn anything.
For those who did not see me play before...
Also, I don't know why, but it feels like the...
What's it called?
The sensitivity is so low.
I tried adjusting it, but...
I don't think it did anything.
I don't know.
But...
We made E-Tina.
Oh, I spelled Tina wrong before.
Oops.
That's fine.
Have you seen any new characters?
I haven't seen yet!
It feels low as hell in this game.
Keep messing with it.
I literally made it like...
Almost Mac.
I guess...
This is the sensitivity, no?
Says keyboard and mouse.
So, I like...
I almost maxed it.
Pinky yogurt tax.
Thank you!
Stop.
You violated the law.
I mean, I did do that.
Let me try.
Let's see if this changes anything.
I can't tell.
Like, it feels like it's lagging.
I don't know.
Adjust my DPI.
It's fine when I'm...
When I'm not in the game.
It's only...
And I'm in the window.
It's not my...
It's not my mouse.
It's the game.
Hmm...
In-game and menu might be different.
Maybe...
What if I'm like upping it so crazy?
And we get in the game and we're like...
I'm getting my whiplash.
Luna, hello!
Thank you so much for a whole year!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
I'll turn it down some.
We'll turn it to like...
70.
And then I can always turn it up.
Cause it was at 50.
We'll just do that.
Okay.
But let's load the game.
Eat Tina.
You guys have to see...
My really beautiful...
Oh!
I killed a guy and I'm gonna join the darkness!
I'm really excited about that.
You guys have to see Eat Tina.
Okay.
I don't remember...
Oh!
Actually, it's not bad at all.
The uh...
The sensitivity.
Yeah!
It's actually...
Okay.
I can open all of these, right?
I can just look.
No one's in here.
Okay.
I can sit...
Let me show you guys...
Eat Tina.
Eat Tina!
Everybody!
She's just as beautiful...
As I remember.
So there's a scene in E.T.
When E.T.
dresses up...
Isn't this a lady?
Just Google E.T.
And you'll see...
You'll see...
It looks exactly like this.
I think I did the best job I ever could have done.
How do I get up?
Wait.
Stand up.
Tina.
Eat...
Okay, there we go.
Eat Tina.
Um...
E.T.
for short.
What's in here?
Okay.
A broom...
There's some gold.
Do you think anybody would know if I stole?
A shovel?
That sounds useful.
And like...
Cheese?
They won't...
They won't notice.
Probably.
Covered pot.
I have to be careful not to steal everything though.
I...
That's really nice!
A burgundy linen shirt?
Wait.
How do I open my...
Is it tab?
No.
How do I open my inventory again?
I...
This is what we're looking like right now.
What am I wearing?
We're E.T.
We're a wood elf.
And we're also a thief.
I wear the sneet class.
She's got hands.
Yeah.
She do.
Wait.
What am I wearing?
I'm wearing a rough...
Leather...
Cure ass.
It's...
Probably...
But this is really nice.
We could wear this to a fancy dinner party, I think.
I'm gonna take it.
If...
If anybody wanted it, they wouldn't put it in a barrel.
Wait.
Let's see what it looks like.
See?
Wait!
Oh my gosh!
That's so nice!
Meet the Q.
Thank you!
Oh, sorry.
Food...
Mogging my Oshi.
What do you mean?
Oh!
The yogurt?
Yeah.
Oh, wow!
This is so beautiful.
Everybody...
Everybody would be like...
Yeah, Tina!
You're...
You're so stunning today.
Oh my gosh!
Nobody's gonna notice.
I definitely don't think I have a bounty.
On my head.
I don't think so.
It's the night time.
Alright.
I gotta...
Wait.
Can you guys...
I'll figure it out.
Hold on.
Quests.
Let's see what we're up against.
We gotta...
We gotta find the heir.
Yeah, that's right.
I gotta go to...
This place.
Phone home.
E.T.
Joffrey told me that the Emperor has an illegitimate son named Martin, who is currently serving as a priest in the chapel of Akatosh in the city of...
Kvatch.
I must proceed to...
Kvatch at once and bring Martin safely back to Waynan Priory.
Yes, yes.
And then this, I gotta go kill a guy.
Oh wait, no.
This is the people that were killed.
Find the heir.
That's what we're doing.
Wait.
What's the...
What's the difference?
Oh!
Is this like our overarching quest?
No!
Wait, no.
This is the one.
The knife in the dark.
Caught on the...
Caught up on the VODs.
Thank you for watching!
I said this one several months ago, but I can imagine your TV model design is a design for a sugar cookie.
Are you saying I'm sweet?
I've been feeling extreme cuteness aggression whenever I watch Minto.
I don't think you can cure that, huh?
Um...
I think...
You're doomed.
Terminal.
Hehehehe.
What's this one?
Seeking your roots.
Oh!
The nerd root.
Um...
This one is the Dark Brotherhood.
We gotta go to the Inn of Ill Omen.
Which, I mean, you kind of deserve it for hanging out at an inn called that, no?
I think you might deserve death if you hang out at an inn of Ill Omen.
Certainly something bad is bound to happen there.
So...
Sorry, Rufio!
We just...
We just gotta go get that guy.
Hehehehe.
It used to be a nice place.
Well...
They've...
They've let it go into the pooper.
The...
The owners.
Hehehehe.
They...
In fact, I think...
What if they are trying to attract...
You know how, like, some hotels will...
Say that they are haunted to attract...
Um...
Like, paranormal investigators?
What if they're calling it the Inn of Ill Omen to attract, like...
You know...
The ruffians.
And...
And such.
Some real kinds.
Hehehehe.
The freaks!
The freaks?
Bow bow!
Hehehehe.
Okay.
Can I...
Um...
Put this on like a...
How...
What do these mean?
We have to activate quests?
Well, tell me where to go.
Oh!
Open a map.
Wait, where am I?
Wait, oh.
Where am I?
Where?
Oh no, I'm lost!
Wait.
Hehehehe.
Oh, there!
Wow, that's far!
We're up here!
We gotta go all the way down here?
Holy cannoli!
Okay.
I can just go through the mountains.
Right?
What?
You can fast travel.
But where's the fun in that?
Oh yeah!
We have a horse now!
So true!
Where's the fun in fast travel?
I gotta...
I gotta get used to these...
To these parts, you guys.
I don't know anything.
Hehehehe.
I'll fast travel maybe in the future.
But I wanna see the world right now.
Oh wait!
Is this not Kvatch?
Is this where we need to go?
What's this one then?
Pilgrim?
Hmm?
No.
No, no, no, no.
Wait.
Um...
Where's my horse?
Horse!
My horse that I borrowed?
For our great adventure?
Horse!
That was given to me by the late emperor.
As his spirit possessed me and told me...
That I have a horse.
You will get a horse that isn't stolen.
Mine's not stolen.
It's borrowed.
Wait, he left?
There's no way.
Oh.
Uh...
Did I ever loot this guy?
I didn't!
He's got some...
I can literally...
I can take his pantaloons.
Wait.
If I...
If I take all of his clothes...
Okay, hold on.
We're gonna make it look like this is only the works of a real...
Of a real like, you know, freak out here.
So I'm gonna take all his clothes.
Oh gosh, I'm heavy.
I'm gonna move them over here.
And then they're gonna be like...
There's some freaker out here...
Who's killing people and stripping them of their clothes!
And then...
They will never suspect E-Tina.
Who...
Who could...
Who could ever suspect such a...
Sweet looking...
Flower child?
Nobody.
Alright.
Now let's get rid of...
Let's get rid of everything.
Look at her!
She could never...
She would never rob a man and then...
Wait.
It's...
Drop.
Oh, nope.
Legion.
Rusty iron...
Are these mine?
I just took off her pants!
Oh my god!
Put them back on E-Tina!
What are you doing girl?
I don't want the helmet either.
It's ugly.
Okay.
Indecent.
Indeed.
Okay.
Alright.
Now the...
Can I...
Can I carry...
Can I carry this guy?
Or...
How do I fight again?
I don't remember.
Oh golly.
Okay.
I have a...
If I equip my bow...
Oh, that's it.
I just have to equip it.
Okay.
Blade of woe?
Wait.
Was this given to me?
Yes.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot the shield.
Okay, hold on.
Get rid of all the evidence.
Except the body, apparently.
Except the body.
They could be like, what?
Actually, they might even just see this and think that he was some crazy drunk.
They're just like...
Oh.
Oh, good morning.
Hello.
Talk.
Um...
Assistance.
Oh, rumors.
I'd like to learn more about spell casting.
Might have to head over to the mages guild and see if they're accepting new members.
I see.
Uh, assistance.
Well, I normally stay out of the affairs of the great folk that come through Wainon Priory to see Master Joffrey.
But go ahead and take this hammer.
You might have use of it.
And I have others.
Not much call for smith work around here in any case.
Well, we both have better things to do than stand here all day exchanging idle gossip.
Okay.
Good day to you now.
I got a hammer.
Nice.
Let's see if we can get a horse then.
Free hammer.
Good morning.
Oh, priests.
Wow.
I stayed in your cottage and there was no food.
Wait, where are they?
Oh, they're asleep.
Wake up.
Good morning.
Yes.
Oh.
Sir, my eyes are down here.
Oh, golly.
Assistant.
Perhaps you will find this useful.
One of the books I saved from my blade strength.
You go into danger.
Joffrey didn't tell us any more than that, but know that our prayers go with you.
Thank you.
What about Joffrey?
Oh, yes.
He'll be in the priory house somewhere.
Don't look down.
He's embarrassed about my t-shirt.
He's like, I must not look upon thy bosom.
E, Tina, you are...
E, Tina, I cannot look at a woman until 12 PM.
Okay.
Thank you.
Oh, look up.
Good day.
Is he gonna go back to sleep, you think?
Oh, no.
He's permanently cross-eyed.
Oh.
Good night.
What about you?
Can I get a horse from you, please?
I know that you are on an important mission for the blades.
Please, if you need a horse, take mine from the priory stable.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you.
That's a generous offer.
Go with Talos's blessings.
Do not fail.
Good night.
I woke him up.
Thank you.
Here, I'm gonna...
I'll keep watch over you guys.
My two little brothers.
All right, let's go get our horse.
Oh, I wonder where our horse is, though.
Where did our horse go?
They think I can just take it now.
Which one is his?
Oh.
Okay, definitely not...
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, way none prior...
He gets...
They get two.
All right, I get the one.
All right.
Red.
Okay, now if I look at the map...
I go to Kvatch, no?
Oh, this is for...
Oh, okay.
That's why it was telling me to go to Anvil.
Okay, no, no, no, no.
We're going to Kvatch.
Wait.
Uh, uh...
Find the air.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I didn't realize I had to select the quest.
Okay, that makes so much more sense.
That way!
Okay, horse.
We're going...
Very slow.
Back it up, horse.
Back it up.
Boop.
Yes.
Oh, yes.
All right.
Horse.
Back it up.
Back it up, please.
Oh, please.
Turn around.
Horse.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
There we go!
And we're off!
Hi-yah!
Actually, I kind of want to look around the area and see if my horse is around here.
You know?
Wait.
What was that?
How do I get off?
There we go.
Don't!
Don't leave!
What was...
What did I just say?
I thought I saw some evidence.
Nothing.
ET?
Well, actually, it's ET now.
Wow.
It's so beautiful!
ET phone home.
Oh, stables.
I could have gotten a horse from here.
Look at that.
There's plenty of free horses here.
What did they want me to do?
Just run the whole way?
Hold on.
What's that?
Wait, those are deer.
That's not my horse.
Alright.
Horse, turn around.
Yeah, they're free.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
Is that the moon?
Crazy.
Okay.
Which way am I going?
This way.
Have a rough day at work.
I'll catch them on.
Have...
Have a nice day!
Thank you!
One of them.
Can my horse get hurt?
Oh, I'm at a fort.
There's a fort here.
I don't see a fort.
No, horse.
Don't do that.
What should we name our horse?
What the heck was that?
Just heard a mysterious sound.
I should have probably studied on the path, huh?
Oh, golly.
Okay.
Be careful, horse.
Uh...
Here's the path.
What's that red light down there?
Uh...
Someone's making breakfast?
What is that?
Let's go investigate.
Yes!
Where are we?
Oh, we're at the fort!
Oh...
What the?
Oh my god.
No, leave my...
Hold on.
I can't remember how to...
Quickly equip my bow.
Leave my horse alone!
Wait.
Ah!
Leave my horse alone!
You're okay, horse.
Are you okay, horse?
Nasty.
Wait.
What's that up there?
Is that a person?
Nasty rats.
Why are there such big rats everywhere?
Oh, no.
Is that a dungeon?
Wait.
Is there a...
Oh, yeah.
That's how I sneak.
That's right.
Okay.
Nice!
How do I get up there?
I did get the crazy jump.
Uh...
Okay, never mind.
Hold on.
Oh my gosh!
Planet Mike, thank you so much for the 50 gift!
Thank you!
Holy...
Holy moly...
Thank you so much!
Alright.
Maybe I can jump from here.
Retina!
Oh sh...
Oh gosh...
What were you thinking, girl?
Can you climb the ropes?
No?
Okay.
It's fine.
She's getting her... her vigor back.
She's just old.
I got old knees.
There's just a guy up there.
I want to loot him.
Oh well.
Okay.
I wanna... I wanna make sure that we get to the place.
I don't wanna do some dungeons for now.
We did our first one before.
That was fun, though.
Alien knees.
Broken ankles.
Where am I?
Wait, this... looks deserted.
Hack dirt.
Um... Is that... good, or...?
Wait, I need to go through hack dirt.
Does anyone live here?
Wait, there's lights on.
Why does this town look so gross?
Oh...
Uh...
Hello?
Moslin's dry goods.
Okay, we got a store.
Moslin's in.
The water's all dried up.
Hello?
Oh!
Oh, dang it.
I forgot how to do it.
I was too slow.
Ow!
It's okay, I have 36 lockpicks left.
Nice.
It's a hillbilly town.
Yee-haw!
You could wait until morning.
Oh, you think they'll be open then?
Uh...
Surely the inn is open.
Oh, see?
Oh...
Good morning.
There's nobody here.
What is this?
Full of ale?
Oh, wait!
This is not illegal.
Huh...
Why not?
Oh!
Uh...
Go, man.
Lewud, what did you do?
What did you do?
Thank you for the...
Hakusupa!
What did you do?
Imagine being born in a place called Hector.
I kind of want to see what's in this person's room.
Can I peek in through the crack?
No?
Oh, maybe?
Can you see in there?
Where is everybody in this town?
Huh?
I'm looking around still for a second.
I want to see what else is...
Why is there nobody here?
Wait.
Guys, how do I put my weapon away?
I don't want people to think I'm...
I'm...
I'm naughty.
F.
Oh.
Thank you!
Natch Pinder's house.
Oh my gosh.
Everybody locks their doors here.
I have a friend.
If she ever comes over...
Whenever she comes over...
She...
Purposefully tries to break into my house to make sure I'm locking my door.
It's night time.
Oh, but...
It's so bright out.
Bible of the deep ones.
Oh.
Oh no, I can't read.
Uh oh.
Oh no.
Alien language.
Given to me by the chief of the deep ones.
He taught me his language and his runes.
This is the ancient lore of his people...
Which we shall follow from now until forever.
Signed in the presence of twelve witnesses.
Urlov Moselin.
Mm-hmm.
I see.
I think it's a cult.
I think it might be a cult.
Do you think the people will be upset with me if I break into their rooms in the inn?
I might be a little excited about a...
About an extraterrestrial visitor.
What's this?
Caverns?
Oh my goodness.
It's a hard block to pick though.
Vivico, I think you're the gifted dequeue.
Let's...
Let's try.
Let's try getting into the person's room.
What are they gonna do?
Wake up?
I'll be really quiet.
Wait.
Is anybody in here?
There's nobody in here.
I could sleep in here.
There's an iron mace in here?
Hello?
Is there somebody hiding behind the...
The curtain?
No?
Let's just have a bunch of bone meal.
Yeah.
Okay.
Where's the loot?
Maybe in here.
Wow.
Nothing.
We got some parchment.
Nothing else.
What was the point?
Hmm.
I could take the iron mace.
It's kind of heavy though.
Oh well.
Stealing is bad.
It doesn't say I'm stealing.
I don't think anybody lives here.
Oh.
I lied.
Uh.
Wait.
What are you doing?
Oh.
Hello.
Um.
Hi.
Where did you come from?
Oh.
I didn't steal anything.
There was a ghost goblin behind you.
Oh.
Where did you come from?
Conjurer.
Isn't that an evil guy though?
Snowball tome.
Gold rimmed shoes.
He's blinged out.
I think we'll take that.
Oh.
Hello sir.
I saved you, didn't I?
Let me give you some advice, stranger.
Leave.
Now.
You ain't welcome here.
I killed your guests.
Gray fox.
I forgot about that.
My grandfather built this place.
Not that it's any of your business.
We've been down.
But we got plans to bring back the good old days.
You'll see.
Mm-hmm.
I guess we've got a room available.
30 gold per night.
Ah, no thanks.
Take it or leave it.
I hacked, actually, the door.
I wall hacked in.
No, thank you.
Then stop wasting my time.
Okay.
I thought you wanted to make this place amazing.
Go bother someone else.
He's so rude.
Wait, can I persuade you?
Go on.
Hold on.
I'm going to do a little bit of a persuading.
Totally not a cult town.
What?
Um.
Okay, how do I do this again?
Alright, so we got to...
We got to make him happy.
He loves being coerced.
He just likes being boasted.
Hates a joke.
Even more hates being admired.
Okay, wait.
So, you do this in the order...
Where there's...
The least amount of...
Oh.
A least amount of...
What's it called, right?
It hit zero.
Oh, it went from 99 to zero.
Uh.
Can I leave?
Don't.
Please.
I'm sorry.
I wish I could say that.
Heh.
That's just not...
Oh, I think I messed up.
Don't talk such rot.
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Sorry.
I'm not...
I'm from a different planet.
I don't have very good people skills.
Go bother someone else.
Okay, Mr. Moslin.
I protected you.
But I'll leave.
You think my horse is still out here?
Oh, gosh.
Mint the Rizlis.
I don't think I understand it yet.
Get my bow and arrow out just in case.
Wait, we can go in here now, right?
No?
It's not open?
Oh, you scared me.
Um...
Was this the only thing over here?
Yes.
How do I check the time?
Natch Pinder's house.
My man, you have a lot that you need to take care of before you fix this place up, okay?
Oh, it's 6.37 a.m.
Bruna, thank you so much for the read.
Thank you for the redirect.
Hello.
Ray Mac, thank you for the gifted.
Wait, so how do I know when it opens?
Hmm.
I didn't kill the employees.
Oh, their little quaint graveyard.
Oh, gosh.
Everything's so...
Run down.
All right.
Well, let's leave this cult town.
We're gonna start our own cult instead.
That's he.
Thank you for the gifted.
Hi, sweetie.
Thank you, guys.
All right.
This...
This way.
Oh.
Go, horse.
Go.
We'll go around.
This way.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, cult town.
I think this is a path.
Nope, I lied.
It's okay.
We don't need a path.
We make our own.
We make our...
Oh, that's a rat.
Keep running.
Take off.
Thank you for the gifted.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, I'm at a house.
Is this rat still following me?
No.
Stop the music, then.
I'm scared.
Oh, yes, he is.
I see him.
Leave me alone.
Oh.
Yeah.
Take that.
Rat scum.
Whose house is this?
Knock, knock.
Weatherly.
What was that?
Oh.
I heard something.
That doesn't look too good in here.
There's bones.
Uh-oh.
Oh, my God.
Uh.
Uh, I don't think...
Oh.
Uh.
I think the owner had a pretty rough time.
Holy cow.
This place is trashed.
You guys hear that up there, right?
That's scary.
Covered pot.
Oh, my God.
Stripped him to the bone.
Let's see what's in here.
I'm scared, though.
I'm scared.
What's in here?
Ghosts, maybe?
You heard the thumping, too, no?
Nah.
I'll take the repair hammer.
I think that's pretty good, right?
We could go minecrafting with a pickaxe.
If there's anything ever that you guys see that might be pretty good, um...
Just let me know.
Because I don't know what's...
Worth it.
Oh.
In this game.
Oh, my God.
Somebody's definitely here.
Oh, I just...
I can use the hammers.
This one, I think it was...
No, this one.
No.
Hammer?
I didn't see a hammer.
Skelly's everywhere.
Oh, gosh.
The music is so whimsical, but my heart is racing.
Oh.
Wait, there's just...
A bunch of skulls.
Is there anybody here?
Oh.
Whatever happened here was a bad, bad time.
Oh, I already picked it up.
Oh, the repair hammer.
Oh.
I thought there was a different hammer.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, because that'll repair my bow and stuff.
Maybe...
Maybe this isn't in for ghosts.
Or skeletons, rather.
Or...
Okay.
Well...
Gosh.
It sucks.
For whoever...
Whoever lived here...
Oof.
What time is it?
You said tea?
8.45.
Well, we're wasting time.
We gotta get to... the place!
Oh wait, is this thing again?
E.T.
Bonhomme.
This thing will grant us a... something.
Continue your penance to earn the god's forgiveness.
My penance?
What am I doing?
I'm not apologizing.
I'm not apologizing for nothing.
What was that?
Hmm.
Alright, let's go horse.
I'm no criminal!
Wait, so if I'm a criminal, I can't get god's blessing?
Will they let me into the town?
This way.
Oh, another abandoned place.
What is up with that?
Aw, the deer are so cute!
Oh, another fort!
Oh, there's probably rats here.
Let's leave.
Rats and or... um... the bandits.
Go horse, go!
Some books can give you skill bonuses, so they're worth a read.
Spell tomes can give you new spells.
Alright, horse.
Come on.
Hup, hup!
Hup, hup, hup!
Horse!
It's just a mountain!
Oh my gosh, it's like we're in... um...
It's like we're in the sound of music.
Wow!
Oh, up the hill once more!
I'm not horsing around.
We're getting straight to the place.
Is that it?
It looks a little frightening.
How do I get down from here?
Uh-oh.
Um...
Wait, what's that horse?
Check it out.
This deer is frozen.
Oh, never mind.
Wait, what do you mean save first?
How do I save again?
Quick save?
I'm quick saving.
Oh, F5.
Thank you.
A lead well.
You draw power from the well.
What am I?
Uh...
Did anything happen?
I got a buff.
Yeah.
Something.
Whatever that is.
Uh...
How can I see what it is?
Magic?
Clairvoyance?
Is that what I just got?
No.
Magic tab shows buffs.
Last tab.
So what was this?
Fortify agility.
Fortify luck.
Fortify magical.
Fortify speed.
Resist disease.
Fancy!
Come on, horse.
Uh...
Huh.
I think I can...
I don't know how much gold I have.
To bribe anybody.
But you know...
Wow, we really are like a mountain goat.
I think maybe any amount could be good.
Look at that.
We went on a little adventure.
I never sold my stuff!
I was hoping I could sell it.
At the place.
I guess they wouldn't have given me good money, huh?
Yeah, you're right.
I never sold any of my things.
I didn't know what to sell!
Wait, what was that?
Oh, my... my horse.
Okay.
But if I tell them that this is very official matter...
Wait.
Dagny's camp.
Who are you?
Are you friend?
Oh.
The deer are kissing.
Are you friend, Dagny?
You won't hurt my horse, will you?
Oh.
Hello?
You're not friend.
You are not friend.
Wait, wait, wait!
No, my horse!
Don't go after my horse!
Oh, my God!
You're the worst!
Hey!
Stop touching my horse!
Why did he go after my horse?
First thing!
You don't have any friends in here?
Oh.
What?
What a scoundrel.
We'll take all his stuff and sell it.
What?
What's that?
Wait, what's in here?
What's in your sack?
Got some food?
My poor horse is taking...
So much damage!
Everybody always attacks you first!
Maybe you're the criminal!
Not me!
Yeah, now this is Minto's camp.
Hear ye, hear ye.
I've taken control.
Alright.
And it's not like he wanted to take my horse.
Why would he try to kill it otherwise?
He was like talking, so I thought he was gonna be a friendly guy.
I guess never trust people that talk to themselves.
Another fort?
Are all the forts dungeons?
Oh!
I forgot to search his body!
You're right!
Yes!
I see!
Thank you guys!
I forgot to search...
I forgot to take him...
Wait.
What's tall...
Wink?
Oh, it might be one of those.
Okay.
Where is his body?
Down here.
Look at the way he's laying.
He's so stiff.
He actually looks so peaceful.
Aw, man.
He's got nothing.
Can you pick him up?
I don't...
I don't think you can pick up bodies, no?
Boots, what the fu...
Alright.
Onwards to the castle.
Or to the...
City.
Whatever that is.
E to drag them!
Oh.
I wish I had seen that before...
With the guy that I killed earlier.
That wasn't a bandit.
I don't think they'll even...
What if we...
What if E-Tina puts on a different wig?
They'll never recognize her.
Okay.
We've explored this place now.
Onwards.
Wait, what is that?
Oh, that doesn't look like a friend.
Okay.
Keep going.
Put on some makeup.
We can put on our...
We have...
We have put on our prettiest gown.
Like, nobody should...
Should be able to tell.
Um...
I think I gotta go this way.
To get up there.
There.
We're getting there, guys.
I saw a house, too.
So maybe there's some people living in there.
Or not.
They could all be...
Deceased.
I wish I could shoot...
On my horse.
You know?
We'll avoid the...
The dingoes.
The Gold Coast!
Sorry that it's kinda stuttering a little bit.
But I haven't been lagging.
Which is great.
Shit comb farm!
That's not very nice.
To call your farm that.
It's a very lovely farm.
Actually...
You have no animals.
Why is it so...
A little goblin.
Wait.
Get my bow now.
I don't want this guy to get me.
I think I can get him.
Shoot.
Oh shoot.
Don't attack my horse.
Thank you.
See guys!
Why is it so...
Oh wait.
Where'd he go?
Where's his body?
I lost him.
I was looking at a pile of rocks the whole time.
Wait.
Where is he?
Oh there he is.
Little imp.
Eyes like a ghost.
I'll put my thing away.
Let's go inside.
Maybe there's somebody in there.
Oh look.
This is nice.
This is so...
This is so lovely.
Somebody's gotta be in here.
Oh.
I've entered what appears to be a recently abandoned farmhouse.
Perhaps if I search around I may find a clue as to the owner's whereabouts.
Continue.
Okay.
We got a new quest.
How exciting.
The owner's whereabouts eh?
Uh huh.
The owner's whereabouts.
Anything in the fireplace?
I don't see anything.
What are these?
Root pulp.
Columbine root pulp.
Leak.
What about in your drawers?
Blue and green outfit.
That's like me.
Hold on.
We got a...
Burgundy linens.
Nobody's here so...
Wait.
Inventory.
Here we go.
Let's put on a new outfit.
Suddenly this becomes a...
Like a dress simulator.
E...
Tina.
It's just me.
Are you kidding me right now?
Wait.
We got the linens.
Oh, sorry.
To match the shirt.
Tina is styling right now.
Which one do you guys like better?
This one.
Or this one.
Her name is E-Tina?
Yeah.
Green?
Okay, we'll go with the green outfit.
I'll put the other one back.
Can I do that?
I wish I could.
I'll drop it on the floor.
Wait.
No!
We can save it.
What?
Oh, whose breeches are these?
It's not mine.
Hit F.
Oh.
I see.
I kind of want to keep them though.
Oh.
It said to search the...
The place to find where...
Wait.
Maybe in the barrel?
I don't know.
Some gold?
I need that for sure.
It said to search to find where the owners have gone, but...
Am I dumb?
Hmm.
There's a note somewhere.
That's a...
That's a knife and a fork.
Do I need to like, move some stuff?
What did the quest say?
Uh...
If I search around, I may find a clue.
Well, maybe it's just a search around, so...
I assumed it was inside.
Could be outside too.
Let's go check.
Hold E to move things.
Yeah, I was trying...
I was doing that, but it wasn't working.
Oh.
Oh, it's not foggy anymore.
Nice.
E.
Fold the claw.
Some more gold?
Take that.
Someone said try X.
Oh.
I could try that instead.
Wait.
If I do it on like...
Is it anything?
No.
Let me try...
A pewter picture.
But it looks like the crops are being maintained.
No?
They couldn't have...
They couldn't have left so long ago.
Hold E.
Hold on.
Let me go...
Let me go try with one of the plates.
Has to be interactable.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's see.
All right.
I'm on this plate.
I hold E.
Oh!
I don't know why...
I don't know my own strength.
Oh, sorry!
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
Where is she?
I think I was trying on the chair and that's why it didn't work.
Hmm...
I don't think it's in here.
Unless...
No.
I don't think the info is in here.
It went...
Wait.
Something fell on the floor?
Oh, did it...
Wait, did it really?
Everything flew.
I couldn't tell.
Oh!
This?
Slythe's journal.
Oh!
I've come across a discarded page of a journal of a Slythe Seringi in an abandoned farmhouse near the ruins of Kvatch.
Ruins!
It mentions some sort of pilgrimage to bring an offering of great value to something called the Sunken One.
All signs point to a sandstone cavern nearby.
I should proceed there, as I fear for Slythe's safety.
I don't even know this guy.
Wait, what is spoilers?
As midnight...
Oh, the...
The quest?
As midnight approaches, I still watch the fires burn.
The great city of man, Kvatch, lay in ruins.
They didn't heed my words.
They didn't listen to my voice.
Now they are all paying the cost of ignorance.
The Sunken One strikes swift and hard.
He swats those who oppose him as if they do not exist at all.
The excuses of man fall upon deaf ears.
The Sunken One has no pity.
He has no mercy.
He only sits below and passes sentence.
And now, with a mighty stroke, he's toppled one of man's pitiful blights on his land.
And yet he still hungers.
His appetite is voracious.
Kvatch will not be the last city to fall by his hand.
The world of man grows more and more corrupt and it angers him.
Man's lies and deceit will be his undoing.
As the Sunken One grows impatient and no longer waits for or accepts the proper offering.
The burden is mine to shoulder.
I am the last who knows of he who shakes the ground.
If I do not bring him the offering, who knows what city may fall prey to his whim.
Anvil?
Coral?
Or perhaps he will turn his eyes on the greatest boil of all.
The great imperial city itself.
No, I must not let that happen.
I must get the offering to him like my father did before me.
Man may be fallen in his eyes.
But they must have time to learn the Sunken One's teachings.
Destroying man now would be a waste.
When I am certain that given the chance, they will come to see his ways.
Don't say yawn, it makes me yawn.
You violated the law by being the eepiest ghost.
I am so eepy all this way.
All this reading...
This note's a snore fest.
Yes, I will do this thing.
I will brave the depths of Sandstone Cavern to see him.
My weapons will be my will and my word.
The Sunken One will watch over me and guide me.
I must depart soon before it's too late.
If anyone finds this page, let them know that I, Slythe Syringi, do this for the good of all men.
Okay.
Syringi.
I don't know, that sounds like a pretty tough mission.
I'm only level 2.
I don't think I can, you know...
I don't think I can take down a dark lord anytime soon.
Thanks, Syringi.
I believe in him.
It's easy!
Oh, there's a road here.
Wait, so it's the fallen city?
So like...
Is there anybody here?
Level scaling.
Wait, who's after me?
Ouch!
Oh my god, my dog!
I mean, my horse!
Hey!
Hey, wolf!
Take that.
You okay, horse?
My horse is so tough.
Everybody attacks you, horse.
Oh, whoops.
What did I just do?
Nope, nothing.
My horse looks a little blind.
You got something in your eye, buddy?
You okay?
Okay.
So then maybe I should do that quest.
What the...
What does...
I pressed Q.
What does that do?
Is it auto walk?
Whoa!
Sandstone...
Sandstone caverns.
Whew.
Where would that be?
184?
Steps away?
Is it not just that guy's house?
I don't know where sandstone caverns are.
Every mission and enemy is scaled to your level, but so are rewards and loot.
For better or worse.
So sometimes you might want to wait to do things.
Ah...
To your next welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Okay, then we'll go to the...
We'll go to the...
This place.
We'll...
We'll ignore it for now.
Cause I...
Don't want to exactly...
Wait.
I see a guy there.
He's definitely not a friend.
Wait.
I saw him over here.
Mortal camp!
Die, mortal!
Wait.
Did I see a guy there?
Maybe I completely hallucinated.
And imagined him.
I thought I saw a bald man's head.
Wait.
I could have sworn I saw a bald man's head.
Why are there just random camps set up?
If I...
If I turn this...
I knew it!
Ah!
You're not bald at all, actually!
You have a full head of hair!
Lockpicks!
Weak, poisonous, feeble mind.
I was right, though!
I was right.
There was a man.
Just not...
Bald.
He heard me call him bald.
Yeah, he put his little toupee on.
He said bald?
I'll show you bald!
They got anything else here?
Nothing?
What a lame...
What?
You're...
You're the worst at your job.
I thought you were a bandit.
You've stolen nothing.
What happened?
Wait, so I can pick him up?
Wait, he's heavy.
Come here.
Wait, come here.
Whoa, don't...
Throw your legs open like that.
Come here.
He's too heavy!
There we go, there we go.
There we go.
I don't even know where I would take him.
I kinda wanna throw him over the ledge, but...
It's a little bit of tough work.
My arms are too scrawny.
Get your arrows back!
I have so many arrows, trust.
I have...
I have so many arrows.
You guys see that guy up there?
Will I be okay?
I have the final DMC...
DMC5 boss sleep stuck in my head since he played.
It's a guard, yeah.
Hello?
Act natural.
Act natural!
Uh oh.
Oh.
Everything's fine.
Hello!
Stop!
Oh!
You violated the law.
You have to lack the funds to pay the cost.
You must serve out your sentence.
Your stolen goods are now forfeit.
Okay, you can take the horse back.
You can take the horse...
Why, bounty is 12...
1200!
Go to jail?
I can't...
It won't even let me resist arrest.
Hope you rot, criminal scum.
Scum.
Wait!
No!
My outfit!
You will get them back when you are released.
Um...
What do I do until then?
Go to sleep to serve your sentence.
Oh, okay.
I'm serving my time.
No!
Wait!
It...
It all happened so fast!
Something's decreased!
Oh.
Oh, here it is.
I thought you said I would get my stuff back.
Oh, here we go.
They couldn't even let me dress myself.
Where's my horse?
Do I have shoes?
Yeah.
Where am I?
Hello.
Hi.
Is my horse...
Is my...
Where am I?
Wait, where am I?
Skingrad!
Where the hell am I?
No, sorry.
I'm here.
Wait.
No, I'm not.
I'm...
Wait.
I'm over here!
What the hell?
Oh, no.
What?
Where am I?
Castle Skingrad.
Oh, my God.
Kabach didn't have a jail.
Oh, well, we can check out this place while we're here.
What is it?
Hello.
What can I do for you?
Um...
Rumors.
Battlehorn Castle, near Coral, is besieged by Marauders.
I wish I could go and save them.
Nah, it sounds tough.
Yeah, bye.
You too.
Oh, no.
She said bye, but I thought she was saying, have a nice day, and I said, you too!
That guy's probably so embarrassed right now.
Maybe now would be a good time to sell some stuff.
Yeah, true!
Where am I, anyway?
Uh...
Barracks?
I'm just a little alone.
E.T.
Extra...
Hello.
Down he is.
Oh, okay.
Oh!
It was only blacked out!
Not that I couldn't select it.
It's that I've already asked about it.
Farewell.
Oh, I could've...
I could've killed that guy.
Dang it.
Don't you recognize me?
I was just in your jail.
I guess he doesn't care anymore.
Oh!
My bad.
Wrong door.
What's over here?
County Hall.
This place is so nice looking.
Oh, I can enter that County Hall.
Anything in your crates?
Oh.
The crates are not open to the people.
This is such a cute little castle.
Oh.
Not open to the people.
They're doing their...
They're doing their rounds.
It's you.
Hi.
Hello there.
Yeah?
Excuse me.
I'm on duty.
I can tell.
If you're looking to learn a bit about conjuration, Silenus Vecinus is a good person to talk to.
Who?
If you're looking to learn a bit about conjuration...
Silenus Vecinus.
Silenus Vecinus is a good person.
What about you?
We're always on duty.
Oh, you need to sleep eventually.
One Guard tells the truth.
One Guard only tells...
Only lies.
I learned quite a bit about how to use a shield from Ambrose Can.
It cost me a bit, but it was worth it.
I don't have enough money even for my own bail, so... the Lord's Manor.
They're still at it.
Okay, let's check out the hall.
Oh, hello.
They're so friendly here.
Especially because I'm an ex-convict.
What's so bad about going to jail?
Because all I did was sleep.
Honestly, it sounds kind of...
Oh, you're talking to him.
Oh, the stats, okay.
Hellhorn Castle near Coral is besieged by marauders.
I wish I could go and save them.
Everybody says the same thing.
I hear.
Bye.
Evening.
Sorry.
You want me?
I'm Shum Gro Yarok, the Count's butler.
Oh.
Buy a house?
I ask myself, do I like you enough to tell you about this?
What?
I am a perfectly paying citizen.
If it's not one thing, it's another.
What do you mean?
The Count is very particular.
You don't want money?
Everything must be just so.
Okay, let's persuade him.
So?
Okay, it's at 25.
Okay.
I have to figure out how to do this.
He likes to be admired.
He likes...
He really likes to be admired.
Um...
He does not...
But this one, it does not have so much, so...
You're a big, fat liar.
Oh, no.
I, um...
That's pretty good.
Okay, here we go.
Really now?
You're such a charmer.
You can't scare me.
I think we got exactly back to where we were before.
We went in a big old circle.
Okay.
Yeah, you like me now, or...?
I ask myself...
Do I like...
Can I try again?
I can.
Make it quick.
Oh!
Look at that.
Don't make me laugh.
Uh...
You can't scare me.
Um...
No, you do me too much honor.
Good one.
Ooh!
When we are better friends, ask again.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
We're gonna be besties.
Say what you're going to say.
Besties, besties, besties.
Oh, my goodness.
Uh...
Joke is the...
Yeah, I get it.
Nice!
Please, I'm embarrassed.
But thank you.
That's just talk.
You're full of it.
Oh!
We're getting it.
I see.
Do you like me now?
I don't trust you enough.
Oh, my God.
All right.
We're getting it.
Joke.
Yeah, I get it.
We're a jokester.
Oh, no.
Oh, that's just talk.
Admire.
What a wonderful compliment.
Don't make me laugh.
Oh, I think we got back the same.
It has to be like 70 plus.
Okay.
Really now?
Yeah, I get it.
Oh, gosh.
Uh-oh.
I'm in trouble.
That's just talk.
Oh, we're in trouble.
You're full of it.
No!
Really now?
You're such a jammer.
Yeah, I know.
You're a big, fat liar.
Oh, gosh.
This is... Ugh.
Ugh.
You can't scare... That's pretty good.
I'm fumbling.
Maybe the hard one... Wasting your breath.
Like that first?
Blah, blah, blah.
What a bore.
Sure.
No, you do me too much.
I hate this video game.
I'm breezless.
Yeah, I get it.
Please.
I'm embarrassed.
No!
Oh, wait.
Here we go.
But thank you.
You can't scare me.
Don't make me laugh.
I keep going in circles.
No, you do me too.
You're a big, fat liar.
Not bad.
Not... Is that so?
Okay, okay.
When I first met you, I wasn't sure about you.
Now that we've talked a bit, I'm not sure about you.
Ugh.
We got way up from 25, though.
So true.
Don't make me laugh.
Good one.
Oh.
Please, I'm embarrassed.
Let's just talk.
Okay, we got up just a little bit.
Only five more.
Look, he's... He's cheesing right now.
I think he likes me.
Let's try.
Look, I like you.
Wait.
You like me?
Look, I like you.
Yeah, you like me?
All right.
He likes us.
Wait.
Start.
You have reached the maximum disposition for this character.
No!
I don't... It's 12 gold.
Every little bit helps.
See?
Was that hard?
Yes.
My bunny.
Count Hasseldor will only consider buyers of distinction.
You just aren't famous enough.
You had to know me to tell me that?
You had to be my bestie to get that information out of you?
Bye.
I'm never talking to you again, shum.
More like, sh-cum.
Oh, hello.
What's going on with you?
I've heard people saying they ran into goblins around here not long ago.
I can't stand those things.
I avoid those things whenever I can.
What is...
What is that?
So long.
Bye.
What is this symbol?
Oh, hello.
I'm Hal Leers.
Count Skingrad's steward.
The count does not accept unsolicited visitors, I'm afraid.
I apologize for the inconvenience.
Austin Adia.
Thank you so much for the vibe.
Good to thank you.
Recently finished MGS3 for 3DS for the first time.
My first Metal Gear game.
Oh, the catch is I knew all the spoilers prior.
But it was still fun.
This got me thinking, which games have you experienced entirely through YouTube?
Oh, there's probably a handful that I've done only through YouTube.
I can't...
Save...
I can't say...
Oh, yeah.
Rebirth.
Yeah, Final Fantasy Rebirth.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I did watch that through YouTube.
Because I watch...
Mainly when I watch like...
Let's Players and stuff.
It'll be like...
Obscure indie horror game.
Kind of, you know, stuff like that.
You're talking to me and I don't like you.
Goodbye.
No!
This better be good.
We can persuade her.
Damn, she's expensive.
Okay.
Um...
She likes to be coerced.
Wait.
She really likes to be coerced.
She likes a boast.
She...
Doesn't like...
To be admired.
Well done.
So I was like...
You think that's funny?
Yeah.
Don't talk such...
Yes, yes.
Whatever you say.
Okay.
It's color-coded.
Not until...
I get it...
Correct, though.
I accept.
I have no choice.
You think that's...
Funny?
I wish I could say that.
Don't waste your flattery on me.
Okay, okay.
Oh.
Wait.
Green...
Wait, which one?
This one is the better one, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
So...
Don't waste your flattery on me.
You think that's funny?
Well done.
Oh, this is like...
Don't please, I'm sorry.
That was like a perfect run.
Wow.
That was like as good as it could go, I think.
Oh my gosh.
Nice.
Um...
I wish I could say that.
Yes, yes.
What?
Not now.
Not later.
That's just stupid.
We're rising her up.
E-Tina is killing it right now.
Yes, yes.
Whatever you say.
Um...
Let's boast.
Really?
Interesting.
What a...
What nonsense.
Yeah!
Okay, okay.
No.
No, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, it won't let me do anymore.
Why?
Please!
You'll have to speak with Shum-Gro-Yah-Rug about that.
He's the only one that can handle the deed.
That guy is useless to me.
Count Skingrad is a very private person.
I handle all the county's public affairs and consult with the count when necessary.
Scum.
Yeah, scam.
Yeah.
More like scam whatever his name is.
My speech craft has increased.
Ayo.
Shh.
Scam.
Grow.
Yarrug.
Screw you.
How goes it?
How do I put my fists away?
Oh.
Okay, I did it.
The count will not see you now.
Not now.
Not ever.
Oh.
He sees no one.
Can an alien and a lizard find love in the court of Skingrad?
Right?
That Dennis Artillion is a little too full of himself.
Sure, he's a captain of the guard, but I'm not impressed.
Wow, that's some real tea.
Okay, okay.
Wander the streets, fields, and public places of Skingrad to your heart's content.
Just don't include me in your social explorations.
What about...
What about bodily explorations?
I'm listening.
He's already at 45.
Maybe he'll really like me.
Let's see.
He really likes a boast.
Hates admire.
Okay, we gotta hurry.
Coerce is okay.
We'll do this.
Really likes the boast.
Such adventures.
How I envy you.
That's just not funny.
Oh, wait.
I messed up.
I can't argue with that.
That's okay.
It's my birthday.
So...
Have some of my birthday fun.
No!
Instead, can you wish me happy birthday in true Mido fashion?
Is it...
Anyway...
Ah...
Made fashion.
Um...
Either is fine.
Wait, but I want to get it right.
Happy birthday!
Moe, moe!
Magical Kyururun!
Birthday beam!
That should work.
Happy birthday!
Yeah.
Um... I don't think we got anywhere with that.
But that's okay.
Uh, we'll do jokes.
Hilarious.
I can't argue.
Don't waste your flattery on me.
Oh my god.
Is his face okay?
It's getting wider.
Is it getting wider to anybody else or is it just me?
Uh, uh-oh.
Unlucky.
Um...
You win this one.
Don't talk such rot.
That's just not gracious.
What a hero!
Uh, oh, oh, oh.
Which one would be better?
Ah!
Not now.
Not late.
That's just not funny.
Uh...
Such adventure.
You've got a point.
I've got a point.
Okay.
Ugh!
I can't talk to him anymore.
Okay, bye-bye.
Farewell.
You said he won't talk to me, but what if...
A visitor, yes.
Oh, who's opened the door?
Wait, downstairs?
Oh, I think he left.
He really didn't want to talk to me.
Is that him?
Is that our guy?
Okay.
I still gotta go find my horse.
Wait.
Some doors are opening.
Lord's Manor.
Okay.
Dining hall.
Why is that even off-limits?
Good evening.
Hello.
Excuse me.
I'm exploring.
What?
I can't even go to the courtyard!
I can't even go there!
But that's where I have to leave to!
Something I can help you with?
Um...
Nah, you don't know anything.
Bye.
I'm trapped.
I'm banned from everything.
Is it because I'm a criminal?
I'm criminal scum.
Oh.
It's night time now.
Well, the other place wasn't so far away.
I believe we can get it.
I believe we can get to there.
Okay, hold on.
Let's activate our quest.
Let's do...
Not the sunken one.
We did that and he told me nothing.
We need to be more famous.
We need to be like an influencer to live there, apparently.
Um...
Find the air.
There we go.
Okay.
That way?
Oh, we're still inside.
What?
Okay.
Oh.
Boy, where am I going?
East gate.
Whoa.
If the smallest wedge is on a negative emotion at the start, pick that one first.
It sets you up better odds of not losing risk.
Yeah, that's what I tried to do before.
Hmm.
10,000.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh, we're at the town now.
Oh.
Is this free?
Okay.
Look at the little fireflies.
I'm not a criminal anymore.
Greetings, Bosmer.
Bosmer?
That's not my name.
My name is Etina.
Guard house.
Wait, we should sell my stuff here.
Oh, it's a wood elf.
Whoa.
Wait, what the heck is this?
If I stand on it, will I get hurt?
My feet are made of...
Hammer and tongs.
What was that?
Oh, my acrobatics increased.
Oh, gosh.
I thought someone was about to attack me.
Hello, fowl.
Oh.
That's an unfortunate name.
One more coin and I can get a pair of shoes.
His eyes are red.
He must be...
His eyes are so red and swollen.
He's probably crying every day about how his parents didn't love him.
To name him this.
It's okay.
It's okay, fowl.
Somebody will love you.
Anyone looking for work should consider the fighter's guilt.
I hear they're always looking for recruits.
Oh.
A guy named Gray Fox.
He's a fairy tale.
Oh, gosh.
The Imperial Watch pretends there is a thief king named the Gray Fox who controls all the thieves in Cyrodiil.
I don't think I...
Of course, it's all just made up to give them an excuse to keep us down.
Yeah.
I...
This guy, I don't trust his eyes.
He might be diseased or something.
Um...
Blessings of stendor upon you.
See, I would give you some...
I would give you some money, but I'm also, you know...
I'm pretty, uh...
Pretty low myself, so...
You know, you understand, right?
Fowl.
Anyway...
I hope you...
There's actually some shoes in here.
You can put those on.
He needs some eye drops.
Swear a coin for the infirm.
Oh, golly.
Okay, I'm gonna leave.
Okay, I can't leave.
Um...
There we go.
Goodbye!
It's raining.
Here we go!
Traitors!
Wait, why can't...
What time is it?
Oh, it's only...
It's not even 10pm!
Please!
Mage's Guild.
Pickpocket shoes into his inventory!
Hello.
Oh.
Druya!
What's a serodilic?
Is that the language?
It's a town, like any other.
Well, go outside and there's the mountains and wines and sheep.
Here in town, though, nothing special.
Okay.
The Mage's Guild runs more or less like it always did.
But we lost quite a few members when the practice of necromancy was banned.
Why was necromancy banned?
Adriana can make you a member of the guild if you can convince her to take her nose out of whatever book she's reading.
I don't know.
I'm not really into...
Wait.
Train?
Purchase spells?
I'm not really into being a mage.
There are rumors that the Nords are attempting to capture the whole of Solstheim.
And remove the Imperial fort on the island.
Oh, gosh.
This guy looks like that guy that appears in your dreams.
It seems that Skyrim is always involved in a border dispute.
You know what I'm talking about?
Farewell.
This guy looks like the guy that... they're like, have you seen this man in your dreams?
Hello.
That's what he looks like to me.
Of course.
Have you seen this man?
Some strange stories about Count Hasildur.
I'm sure they couldn't be true, though.
Maybe there's something strange going on.
But Skingrad is a well-run city.
I have a question.
Are, like...
Goodbye.
Are, like, a lot... are there timed missions in this game?
Or if it's like, I don't get to the city in time, or something, something?
I'm listening.
Please, go ahead.
What?
No?
Oh, okay.
That's so nice.
I'm rather busy right now.
Oh, is this about joining the Mages Guild?
I suppose I could spare the time, if necessary.
Oh, sure.
Uh, yeah, I'll join... okay.
Join the Mages Guild.
Why not?
You're interested in joining?
Great things will be expected of you.
Are you sure you're ready for it?
Just for lore, they make it seem urgent.
Okay, that's so...
That's so... such a relief.
Wait, can I join multiple things?
Can I join multiple guilds?
There's no downside.
You can?
Okay.
I join the guild.
Then, you are now an associate of the Mages Guild.
You must receive a recommendation from every local guild hall in Cyrodiil before you may advance through the ranks of the guild.
In the meantime, as a member of the guild, you now have full access to the guild halls around Cyrodiil.
Only the Arcane University is closed to you.
Oh.
Because I'm stupid.
I joined the Mages Guild.
Cool.
Um...
What?
You want a tour?
Can't you see I have a lot on my mind?
Go bother a beggar or a guard.
They stand around and chatter all day.
I just joined!
Why are you so rude to me?
She...
She butters you up to join the guild, and then once...
Once you're in, she verbally abuses you.
Okay, fine.
It's been the home of the Mages Guild for the longest time.
You should see the library they have there.
Except I can't because you barred me from the...
...university.
I only make the trip if I can't find a specific book here.
I can't go to the university!
You said I can't go there!
I don't mean to gossip, but he is more than a bit strange.
However, he's always been tolerated as the town eccentric.
Okay.
Who?
Glarthir?
Glarthir.
Recommendation.
I'm afraid I haven't given it much thought.
I'm rather busy, you understand.
My research occupies nearly all of my time.
Oh.
Now that I think about it, I do have a small problem concerning Erthor.
Erthor?
He's one of the guild mages here.
Think you can do something about it?
Glarthir is a funny guy?
Okay.
Oh, sure, I'll take it.
Excellent.
I just don't have the time to search for him again.
But I do need to consult him about some notes he borrowed.
Okay.
You might want to ask around and see if anyone can be of some help.
Let me know when he's back and you'll have your recommendation.
Oh!
So I'm looking for a guy.
Have Erthor see me when he gets back, associate.
Erthor associate.
I have a name.
Please.
I'm Etina.
I'm very respectable.
Wait.
Now I can take anything in here.
Because I'm a member of the guild!
Oh.
I didn't even...
Wait.
Soul gem.
Fundamentals of alchemy.
I was interested in these fire salts.
I've heard some strange stories about Count Hasildo.
Oh, here.
I'm sure they couldn't be true, though.
Maybe there's something strange going on.
What is it, associate?
Oh!
It's...
Ah!
Sinus Valinus!
We found him!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Come back, come back.
Don't leave.
I hear you got quite a task from Adriana.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um...
Skingrad.
Have you met Adriana Berenna?
Our Skingrad mages guild head?
Not the most pleasant person, I'll admit.
Heh.
Don't mind her.
What was I supposed to do with this guy?
I can't remember.
Do the conjuration courses, and Druja does the mysticism.
Is he okay?
Probably not.
Um...
Rumors.
Necromancy may be legal in Cyrodiil.
But few will openly admit to practicing it now that the mages guild has banned it.
Oh, the conjuration.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm here to help if you need me.
Thank you, sir.
Oh, we can go into the basement.
Oh.
I have a key!
The mages guild key!
Maybe they left some gold in here.
Oh my gosh.
I can...
I can eat?
Wow.
Being a member of the guild is awesome!
Everything is free!
Huh.
Good thing I don't have to eat or do anything in this.
In this game.
Don't mind me.
What?
What do you mean by that?
Electurn.
Biography of Berenziah.
Oh, I didn't...
Uh...
What is that?
Okay.
Hello!
Hello there!
Viggy.
Greetings, apprentice.
Well met.
I've seen Shamir at the Tamika Vig...
Green brocade doublet.
He's really good.
I might try to get some...
Hold on.
Hold your horses, everybody.
Oh!
I need pants for this one.
We've got some burgundy linens.
Wait, this one's cleaner than...
This one's cleaner than our current outfit.
This one's cleaner.
Because this one's got dirt all over it.
It's disgusting.
I think we should...
I think we should change.
Wait.
I don't need a ring on.
I'm gonna sell that.
Wait.
What's this?
Folded cloth.
Green silk garment.
Hold on.
Enjoying Minto's new Elder Scrolls era.
Always refreshing to someone play Oblivion for the first time and getting immersed in the shenanigans.
I'm immersed.
Oh!
Wow!
She's really styled.
Okay.
Let's put these in here.
Someone might wash them.
You know what I mean?
So...
Uh...
When did I get this?
Oh!
That's a mushroom.
Hehehehe.
How do you do?
Alright.
Let's go find that guy.
Uh...
He's the eccentric one.
We got an inn here.
Fighters guild?
I could join all the guilds.
Hahaha.
Let's see over here.
West gate.
Nothing.
Remenbroder's house.
This guy might have a bed.
Yeah, it's kinda rainy, huh?
Oh!
Gosh, you scared me.
Raymond Broder.
Retired archer.
An archer!
That's what I am.
Wait, an archery?
That might be good for me, actually.
Not only does Shamir make a good mind...
And thank you for the bread!
He's really good with his bow, too.
I heard he'll train you.
For a fee.
Wait, that's good!
That's good!
I served as a legion marksman for 20 years.
I retired here to Skingrad.
Work in the vineyards.
And supplement my income as an advanced trainer.
Okay.
Wait, so who is it?
I don't mean to gossip.
But he is.
Oh, that's Glarthir.
Not only does Shamir make a good wine...
Shamir!
Shamir at the vineyards!
Okay.
What do you have upstairs?
A bed?
Goodnight.
For...
Until morning.
What, like...
Eight hours?
Yeah.
Oh, oh.
Oh my god!
Who are you?
What's happening?
Oh, I was just looking.
Who was that lady?
Wait.
Hold on.
We gotta go find her.
I heard her leave.
There, you!
Aren't you an ugly one?
Oh, you're one to talk.
I don't have time to talk.
Mysterious note.
Hey, I don't read them.
I just deliver them.
Okay.
Hi.
My Verna.
I have things to do.
What, is this like the dumpy part of town?
Goodness.
It's ugly over here.
Alright.
Ugly.
Over here!
Yes, you...
We can't talk here.
Too public.
Meet me behind the great chapel at midnight.
Don't let anyone follow you.
I'll make it worth your while.
Okay.
Oh, I just slept though.
Midnight?
Oh, wait.
How did it become 4am?
I slept for like 8 hours, no?
Wait, wait, wait.
Come here.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
We can't be seen talking together.
Bye-bye.
No.
I don't know the way to the Imperial City.
You'll have to ask someone else.
The lady woke me up.
Okay.
I'll put my fist away.
Uh...
Okay.
Um, well then.
What should we do?
Okay.
Wait.
I found the guy.
I found him.
Hahaha.
You could sleep in the guild.
Yeah, let's go back to the guild.
Runnin', runnin', runnin',
runnin', runnin'.
Ha!
Alright.
What's this place?
Oh, this is the inn.
I don't want to spend money there.
That's the fighter's guild.
Not allowed in there, apparently.
Everybody's asleep, that's why.
Check the note.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're right, you're right.
Our note.
Uh...
Miscellaneous?
Mysterious note.
Oh!
I can offer you greater rewards and less time in prison.
If you are interested, come to the garden...
Gar...
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Come...
Come to the garden of Derloth in the Imperial City's waterfront district at midnight.
Present this note and all shall be made clear.
Gray Fox!
Ah!
Oh my god!
No freaking way!
Wait, where are the beds?
Upstairs?
Ah, the living quarters!
Nice!
Wait, so...
Oh!
Uh...
What time is it?
Do you guys all wake up at 4.49?
Or...
Wait, why did they just go in there together?
Oh!
What is it, associate?
What you're having...
Is this...
Ah!
Can I join?
Be Frank Yeager.
Oh, sorry.
I'll leave.
I'm here to help if you need me.
Thank you.
You're...
You're so kind.
Most people are not so kind to me here.
Don't mind me.
I'm just checking out the...
The...
The wares.
And I moonwalk out.
I'm gonna sleep with this lady.
If I sleep for...
Until midnight...
How much time would that be?
12 hours would be 5 p.m.
6...
7...
8...
9...
10...
11...
18 hours?
19 hours is...
So if I do 18 hours...
Wait.
But I don't know where to go.
So I'm gonna do...
I'm gonna do...
A little...
A little more...
So that...
Or a little...
Like a little less.
So that I can find it.
Time is really fast here.
Where was I supposed to go?
Oh, do I wanna trade?
You're right.
Let's go trade first.
Uh...
I'm lost?
Wait, here it is.
Wait, what's this?
Display case?
I'm part of the guild.
Why is it locked, huh?
Latest dream of glad to be here.
Greetings, apprentice.
Thank you!
Well met.
Is it me, or is it quieter around here with Urthor missing?
Urthor.
Of course.
Uh...
No, not the Imperial city.
We're trying to do...
Uh...
G...
Glizzi's.
Hammer and Tongs.
Oh gosh, where was that place?
I was trying to find.
There was a...
Larthir?
Yeah.
Him.
There was...
A...
Store...
That was like...
Traders, or whatever.
I lost it.
Have mercy.
Just one coin.
It's next to the Mage's Guild.
It is?
Book it.
Book it, E.
Tina.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da...
Da-da-da-da-da...
It was right in front?
My bad.
Wait...
I'm a little lost.
Where did I come from?
This way.
Riiiight...
No!
This way.
Here...
Alright, let's...
Let's...
Let's sell our stuff.
Let's make some more money.
Hello.
What?
Hi.
Marie Palliella is quite a hard worker.
She's in the chapel, day and night, tending to the sick and injured.
What?
Thank you.
Goodbye.
Hello.
Welcome to Kolovian Traders, Skingrad's finest selection of general merchandise.
Gunder.
I'm Gunder.
Just let me know what you want.
I don't want anything, actually.
I want to sell.
Ah, let's do business.
Okay.
If I, um... What all should I sell?
I have so much stuff.
Okay.
Chameleon.
Haggle first.
Oh, do I haggle first?
Oh,
okay.
Hold on.
If I... So, should I raise him?
Like, should I persuade and, like, make him...
We'll see.
Yeah, we'll see.
Okay.
He really... Nope.
He really likes...
Really likes a joke.
Oh, this is not... This is unlucky.
Uh...
This is unlucky.
Well done.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, no.
Oh, I like that.
Wait, I think I'm...
A lot.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Uh...
That's just... Don't waste your flattery on me.
Uh... Okay.
Oh, joke.
Oh, where'd you get that?
Not now.
Not later.
Not ever.
Really?
You're wasting your breath.
Okay.
We redeemed.
We redeemed?
Oh, no.
Why?
So unlucky.
Uh...
I guess...
Course?
That's just talk.
Joke?
Oh, where'd you get that?
That's...
Remarkable.
What nonsense.
Ugh.
I don't think we got any more...
Um...
Don't waste your flattery on me.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Well done.
I messed up.
Is that so?
That's great.
Eh...
How's it go again?
Okay.
We went up a little bit.
We've gone up a little bit.
Oh.
Okay, here.
Not now.
Not later.
Not a...
Remarkable.
Oh, I like that.
Oh, no.
That's just talk.
Okay.
It is getting better, though.
Yeah, yeah.
We'll do that.
Well done.
Is that so?
Oh, shoot.
Never mind.
I messed up again.
Say, that was nonsense.
We're almost to 70.
No!
I can't do any more.
But he likes me a little bit more.
You're good.
I'm good.
Wait.
I might.
Did you forget a word in between notes in the middle of the sentence?
There's like a little...
Like a little fluff word you could add in there.
You know?
You could just add a little something for an extra...
He's listening.
He's nodding.
I've had about enough of Sir Lazar.
He thinks he's so much better than everyone else.
Safe line, Vito.
You're pretty good.
I like Skingrad just fine.
Folks are a little quiet by Skyrim standards.
But they're friendly and loyal when they get to know you.
Mm-hmm.
All right.
Let's burn.
Only quality goods for sale here.
What can I interest you in?
So now I haggle.
It didn't change anything.
Oh!
I see now.
Because my disposition is better.
You think like halfway I could do?
Maybe like...
75%...
I could do.
Maybe.
Maybe?
Try 60%?
So low.
Did it work?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I have to sell the stuff first.
That's right.
Okay, we'll sell you.
Wait, can I...
Sell a bunch of things at once?
Because that would be nice.
Oh, my God.
It worked!
I think he likes me.
Crank it up higher.
65.
No deal.
Oh.
Okay.
62.
Make me a better offer.
Oh.
Sixty what?
Sixty?
You drive a hard bargain.
Okay.
I will do the sapphire.
I don't... like I said, I don't know...
Great deal there.
Oh, gold nugget.
I don't know what I need to keep for stuff.
So, I'm just gonna sell a bunch of things.
A fine transaction.
Yes, sir.
See, I have 231 arrows.
Sell the goblin staff.
You don't think I'll need it?
It is worth a lot of money.
Folded cloth, I'll sell.
Flower.
It's not heavy, I'll sell.
VTuber, you are leveling the wrong stats.
You must level these abilities instead.
Or you are wrong, VTuber.
Oh, okay.
So, for the petty...
Soul gem...
Why is this one so cheap?
And this one's so expensive?
One has a soul in it.
Oh.
I see.
I don't see.
Has it...
A soul in it.
Okay.
Let's see.
We can get rid of...
Sapphire.
The scales.
You drive a hard bargain.
The goblet.
That seems a fair price.
The nuggets.
A good price for a good...
Yeah.
Var...
Wait.
I didn't read this.
I think I meant to.
What's the varla stone?
Is that the thing I'm taking?
Or the statue.
Bronze amulet.
I sell.
Do-do-do-do-do.
Um...
Recharge is all enchanted weapons.
Oh!
Do not sell the statue.
Yeah, we got that from the quest.
Or from the dungeon.
I do remember.
Sell some...
Sell the food, I guess.
I don't need to eat.
Sell my pants.
Uh...
Are these the stones that I got from the...
So I could sell almost all of them, no?
These are the stones that I got...
In the...
Um...
The dungeon.
I think I was told that I only need like one or something.
So...
Sell like...
I'll sell two even.
Or I'll keep two.
Oh my gosh!
We're getting so much money!
I do have a lot of torches, but they don't weigh anything and they don't sell for anything.
So...
Nice!
It's easy to get more of these?
Oh, okay, cool.
Steel short sword.
I'm gonna keep that just cause I need another weapon.
A rusty iron greaves.
I should wear those, actually.
Sell my shirt.
I got my shoes on.
Okay, okay.
Sell some potato.
Sell potato.
Um...
Sell the mutton.
I guess?
Oh, wait.
I have gold trim shoes.
Get rid of these shoes.
They're gross.
Ugly.
Horrible.
I think we should be good now.
Got some ale.
I got rid of most of the...
Whatever stuff.
Thanks for being cool.
Ha ha ha ha.
Okie dokie.
Wait, do I need these?
They only provide two defeds.
But they're 18 pounds.
They're so heavy.
No?
Okay.
Goodbye.
It's heavy armor.
I appreciate your business.
Thank you.
I appreciate too.
Take care.
Gander.
Um...
Alright, let's go back in.
I'm gonna put on my new shoes.
I wanna see what they look like.
Oh, my head's in the way.
Look at that!
Wait, with no shoes on.
The toes are out.
There we go.
Perfect.
Try sorting it by weight and see what's heaviest.
Oh, I guess so, right?
The staff...
Isn't any good!
I don't know if I should keep it or not.
It's like...
Did bro make ET?
Yeah!
Meet ETna!
Ditch the staff.
It's a low-level spell.
It's a noob weapon!
Hey, hey, hey!
Oh!
Sorry.
What can I do for you?
I would like to sell again.
Can I interest you in some of my wares?
What do you have?
Blue velvet outfit.
Okay.
We got the burgundy linens.
We could get one that's actually, like, you know...
Clean.
Probably.
I have an iron bow, too, no?
Let me make sure.
I have a steel bow!
But mine's better.
Heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh.
I don't need your stinky iron bow.
Okay.
I think we're still at the same, right?
Haggling?
Yeah.
Alright, let's get rid of this.
Staff.
Okay.
Thank you!
Good day.
Thank you.
He's literally that meme of people with blue eyes.
Woohoo!
You can buy spells that are better than that staff at a guild.
Okay.
It's 6 PM.
Let's go find...
Let's see if maybe under the quests...
Oh my gosh, I have so many now.
Oh...
I met a mysterious...
Yes, yes, yes.
Who asked me to meet in behind the great chapel at midnight tonight.
Okay.
Where is that?
Oh, over here.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
I wanna make sure I know where we're going before I just wait, you know?
Good evening.
I guess here?
Is behind the chapel?
It seems.
Check your map.
True.
The great chapel!
Yes, sir.
Let's go in.
I actually dropped a mixtape on YouTube.
Glarthir?
What's new with you?
I ran into some goblins in the woods not long ago.
Nasty little beasts.
Goblins?
Ugh.
Evil, foul-smelling little brutes.
Farewell.
Greetings, Bosma.
You're saying this...
At the altar?
Rejoice!
Through faith your afflictions are banished!
Ah!
Not for long, though.
I'm about to join the guild of the Brotherhood.
Good to see you.
Atahorn Castle, New Floral is besieged by marauders.
I wish I could go and save them.
Go on.
We are all talking about the Emperor's murder.
We have no Emperor and no heir.
That's never happened before.
We do have an heir.
We should all be worried.
I just don't think about it.
The Elder Council will take care of things.
Sooner or later.
So I've heard.
I just don't think about it.
Yeah, Glarthor.
Don't you think?
Of course.
What's the news from the other parts of Tamriel?
I understand Daedra worship has become increasingly prevalent in the Somerset Isle.
It seems Somerset Isle has become a much more dangerous place.
Take care.
Good day.
Hello there.
Well met.
Dandelion, happy birthday!
Can you tell me your favorite thing about my Kamiyoshi?
Her name is...
Mint Phantom.
Um...
I like when she does this.
Happy birthday Dandelion!
I'm sorry I missed it yesterday!
What's this about?
What are you about?
Oh no.
I don't...
This is not a restroom, sir.
I like that too.
It must be a lonely existence.
Okay, bye.
Alright, let's go over here.
How fast has time passed?
Let's wait.
One hour, eight, nine...
Ten...
Eleven...
Let's wait until eleven.
You're doing great, boss.
Thanks, Cinderethylos!
Thank you!
Okay.
We're waiting.
How fast...
Wait.
Ah, you came!
You're sure you weren't followed?
I don't think so.
I thought I could trust you.
Nobody else in town.
They're all in on it.
All watching me.
Well, yes.
I need you to do something for me.
Okay.
I'll pay you...
Gold.
You like gold, don't you?
Aha.
Ooh.
He knows too much.
I need you to check out some people for me.
The ones who are following me.
Watch them.
See where they go.
Who they report to.
Will you help me?
Yeah?
Very good.
You won't be sorry.
For the gold?
I'll pay you well.
Did I say that already?
Let's start with Bernadette Penelis.
Be outside my house at 6am.
You'll see her watching me.
See where she goes and who she reports to.
We'll meet here again tomorrow night.
Again.
Oh, and never contact me in public.
They're watching.
Never.
They can't know you're helping me.
You sure whisper loud.
Her house is almost directly across the street from mine.
Southwest of the Great Chapel.
Coincidence?
I don't think so.
Well, where is your house actually?
There's so much I could tell you.
So many secrets.
But then you'd be in danger too.
Then I'd have to kill you.
It's best if we're not seen talking.
Hi.
For you, of course.
Oh, he likes me.
Alright.
Guys, I gotta actually...
Remember, Bernadette Penelis.
6am.
Bernadette Penelis.
Don't let us see you watching.
I gotta use a little ghosties room, but...
We gotta talk to Bernadette.
Wait, it's not even midnight.
Midnight.
It's not midnight, mister.
Whatever, I guess.
Um...
Bernadette.
Wait, I guess we can look at the map, huh?
Go to the ghosties room.
I'm going!
Give me a second.
It said it was like...
Ah!
Okay.
Alright, I'll be right back.
I gotta pee.
I'll be right back.
Wait, I'll do his funny face.
Oh, sorry.
Forgot to unmute.
I'm back!
Sorry.
For the wait.
Thank you for waiting.
Thank you.
Yes.
I got more tea.
Yes, I did.
And maybe a little snack.
Let's see.
She's right here?
Here?
Okay, now I'm just gonna...
Wait, who are you?
I need to see Chibi Minto again.
Oh!
Oh, sorry.
Why are you doing that at midnight?
People, everybody's trying to sleep!
Can I share a secret that makes lockpicking easier?
I only learned recently.
Wanted to ask first to not backseat.
You know what?
Go ahead.
Oh yeah.
Wake up!
It's midnight!
Actually though, I did watch a video on lockpicking.
I just probably need to watch it again.
Oh.
I'm trapped.
But I can't go in there anyway.
So let's wait for a couple of hours.
And then...
Golly, we're doing a lot of waiting, huh?
Wait five hours.
Okay.
Oh, the beautiful sunrise.
Oh!
Hi!
He's like, why have you been standing here all these hours?
Don't stare at me!
You're gonna make it so obvious, Glarther!
Gosh!
Stupid!
He's like, don't interact with me.
Then he just...
stares at me.
Um...
So...
Wait, why is it 1am?
Wait, what do you mean?
Did I get...
Did I get interrupted by that guy?
A little bird told me that you've been asking around town about Glarther.
A resident eccentric.
I'd like to know why.
Uh...
Dion?
Um...
Uh...
I'm just curious about him.
Fine.
Play it that way.
Let me give you some friendly advice.
Glarther is crazy.
Maybe harmless crazy.
Maybe not.
I think Glarther can match my freak.
If he asks you to do anything...
strange...
You come see me first.
Got it?
Or any of the town guard.
Let us handle it.
What?
Um...
I'm gonna keep doing what I was supposed to do?
Do you know when the plushies got on the second wave of the first day?
And the mugs are shipping.
I'm worried I might have to move places before getting them.
Um...
The plushies?
Like you got the first round of plushies?
Because if you got the first round...
And not like the...
The second one?
Um...
I would message...
I would email...
Um...
Uh...
Support.
Moso box support.
And then...
The mugs should be shipping out soon.
But I can contact them again too.
Because they told me...
What the hell?
You don't need to ring at every hour of night!
It's 2am.
Sounds like they got the second round.
If it's the second round, then it was gonna be...
I think shipped around...
June or so.
You tap the pin repeatedly until the pin...
Moves a lot slower than usual.
So...
And that's when you want to try and set the Tumblr.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah.
That's I think what the video...
That I watched said too.
But yeah.
If you're worried about moving...
Just send an email to...
Um...
Uh...
Oh gosh.
I forgot the support...
One for my store.
But for Moso box...
I'm sure they have it in there...
On their Twitter.
I can get it.
Oh, hello.
Oh my gosh.
You're making it so...
Glarther, go home!
Oh.
He listened to me.
Sexy...
Made ghost VTuber woman.
Oh.
Thank you.
What time is it?
Let's wait...
Uh...
Three more hours.
Alright, finally.
We're not interrupted.
Ah...
Good morning!
What is this place called?
Scum guard.
Skin...
I'm not talking to you!
Leave, Glarther!
She's about to come out any second.
God.
Skin town.
Here, I'm gonna hide right here and see what she does.
Alright.
Okay.
She's coming out soon.
6 AM.
6 AM!
Okay, any second now?
Any...
Oh, oh, oh gosh!
It's 6.
Thanks.
Sorry.
Um...
Uh...
Huh?
Is she doing the stalking mission?
Uh, I think so.
I'm supposed to be.
There she is.
I think.
She doesn't even look at you her way.
Oh, hello.
Oh, hi.
Can I...
Do I talk to her or...
Or do I follow her?
Okay.
Bye.
She goes to church and she prays.
I'll sit next to her.
I'm Bernadette Penelis.
I work for Tamika.
I grow grapes for her wines.
Hahaha.
Where are you looking, Bernadette?
Uh...
I've lived here all my life.
Grown grapes.
It's all I know.
Fresh air, mountains, the grapes on the vine.
It's just...
Beautiful.
I don't think she cares at all about this guy.
Farewell.
Wow, if you joined the, uh...
The Mages Guild, your outfit would be as clean as mine.
Just saying.
Hail.
No, it's sunny today.
Uh...
Arahorn Castle near Coral is besieged by Marauders.
I wish I could go and save them.
I hear you.
Is she gonna...
Who the heck is that?
Wait, who is this guy?
Good thing he's cautious.
I'd hate to have something go wrong.
I am Ambrose Cannes.
Grape grower for Cirilli Brothers.
I'm also an advanced trainer for weapon and shield parries.
Shield parries.
Whoa.
Be seeing you.
I don't think she's gonna do anything.
Can I sit here?
No.
Are they all great people?
I think so.
Talos.
Zenithar.
Mara.
Uh...
Chimeras?
Ooh.
She's leaving.
Hail.
How are you?
Hello.
I'm stalking her.
Leaf.
Oh, my bad.
I punched the door.
Oh, no.
E-Tina doesn't know how doorknobs work.
I put my fist away.
Thank you for Super Chat.
Errm.
No time to talk.
My children are starving.
Please help.
Can't you see that I'm very busy?
Clarthur, you're very rude.
That's what you are.
Oh.
Gosh.
Well met.
Damn, Tamika.
Clarthur, do you have children?
I don't believe him.
I'm just following her all day.
Ugh.
Hmm.
No kids in Oblivion.
Wait, are there...
Actually, now that you mention it, I don't think I've seen a single one.
Good to see you.
How do you do?
Really?
It's good to see me?
Uh-oh, we lost her.
Oh, never mind.
Kids are bad.
Is it because you could kill the children?
And they're like, nah, we don't want you to do that.
What?
Why are you walking like that?
I'm just trying to follow her.
Oh, that's not my horse.
Oh wait, this is where the vineyard is.
Wait, this guy...
Morning.
Oh my gosh, I thought you were an executioner, mister.
You scared me.
Oh.
Hello.
Hi.
I'm also looking at the vineyards.
I haven't been to this area before.
We'll watch her from afar.
Wait, who is she...
She's walking with that guy.
How suspicious.
Hello, David?
There was one guy...
Oh gosh, I can't remember the name.
But they said he did the...
The vineyards.
I've harvested some grapes.
He did the vineyards and he was the archer.
Talos the mighty.
Talos the unerring.
Talos the unassailable.
I...
Talos...
Oh my gosh, she's just working here.
She really is a vineyard lady.
Was it Shamir?
Grape thief!
Would they actually get upset at me?
It's not...
It's not red.
I took your grapes.
I'm a fair-handed grapes and bows.
Yeah!
I'm a grower and trainer.
But I suspect you want to shoot, not grow grapes.
Am I right?
I want to shoot!
Yeah, I want to shoot.
You've got a lot to learn.
This person cannot help you train any higher.
What?
What do you mean?
I'm an apprentice.
You are also an apprentice?
He's not any better than me.
Why was everyone...
Why was everyone like making him seem like he's the best?
Yuros is a good shepherd, but his real love is cheese.
Of course, there's no money in herding cheese.
Riemann Broder.
He works Surly's Vineyard.
I work Tamika's Vineyard.
Riemann spent 20 years in the Legion.
And he's an advanced marksman trainer.
You too.
So, Legion.
Wait.
Or what was his name?
Oh!
Oh no!
I lost her!
Oh, just kidding.
Wait.
So, who should I...
Wowie!
One year!
Alan!
Thank you!
Riemann.
Where's Riemann at though?
I talked to him before.
Oh!
Oh yeah!
That guy said that he won't train anybody anymore.
I did sleep in his bed.
You're right!
I slept in his bed!
Wow!
Whoa!
I want to smash in the...
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh wow!
Guys, have you ever heard about the spiders that are in the cranberry pools though?
I used to always want to be a cranberry...
Like...
Smasher...
Not Cranberry Smasher.
But...
But you know how like...
You can go into the pools with the cranberries and harvest them?
But there's spiders all in there!
Like...
You get covered in spiders!
Yeah!
I'm afraid that this quest is boring.
I hate this.
Why would you say this?
Well I was thinking about mashing...
Mashing grapes with my feet.
And then I was just like...
Oh, I always wanted to do that.
But not with the cranberries.
Because...
This is so inefficient.
All our sheep are gonna leave.
But...
Now...
Because of...
You know...
The spiders...
Definitely not with cranberries.
I don't want to touch that.
Someone had to slip some cash money in one of these.
Someone...
Somewhere...
Oh!
Lockpick!
I'll take that.
Lady is still there.
What should I do?
Just wait until midnight again?
And be like...
Hey buddy, I think you're crazy.
You're insane!
Okay, but...
Whose horse is this?
Is it yours?
Tilna?
Oh!
Tilna!
If you want to buy a horse.
She's inside.
Trade offer.
I give you grapes.
Spider free.
And you step on them.
Without shoes.
And then you give them back to me.
Uh...
I would like to haggle.
Anyone looking for work should consider the fighters guild.
I hear they're always looking for recruits.
It sounds like I'm putting in most of the work.
Good day.
And getting none of those spoils.
What is it?
You want a horse?
I can sell you one.
There are no finer bay horses than those sold.
I have a grateful past stables.
I wonder where my horse is though.
How much is a horse?
Our bay horses are faster than the paint horses.
And tougher than the chestnut.
You'll be proud to own one.
Oh wow.
Did you say 1,000 gold?
She didn't say a price at all.
You mean you're too poor.
That's a fair price for this horse.
Um...
I got both of my horses for free.
So...
Poo poo to you.
Stop talking.
Okay.
I'm not allowed to sleep here?
It's illegal?
Fine.
If you fast travel somewhere, your horse will appear.
Oh!
But isn't it more exciting to go find my horse on an epic journey?
She's still there!
Wait.
My acrobatics is increasing.
Nope, nope.
They're back to work.
It's a hard knock life for her.
She's always...
Plowing...
Plowing the land!
Sorry.
My voice is icky.
And I never give her a hand.
It's a hard knock knife!
Okay.
What else can I do?
We found the guy that I thought would train me.
And he won't.
Or he can't.
Because I'm better than him.
And then...
I...
Yeah, I sold my stuff.
Little lord tidbit about Talos.
Talos is the first emperor who became a god.
Oh.
Um...
I'm just like stalking her.
But she's literally not doing anything.
What can I do for you?
She's got nothing...
I'm listening.
I'm gonna become her friend.
She hates...
Admir...
She likes a joke.
She really likes a boast.
Okay.
Jokes are good.
That's pretty good.
Don't try to manipulate me.
Okay.
Sorry, lady.
That's amazing.
Is that so?
Oh.
Um...
Let's see.
Ugh.
Unlucky.
Again.
So unlucky.
You can't scare me.
Don't waste your flattery on me.
I didn't think that one through.
I didn't think that one through at all.
Hero.
Uh...
Oh my gosh.
Again.
Uh...
Okay.
Um...
Uh...
Not bad.
Don't waste your flattery on me.
That's amazing.
You can't scare me.
Not great.
Not great, guys.
Oh, gosh.
It's going down again.
I hate this.
Uh...
That's pretty good.
That's amazing.
Oh, this sucks.
Let's just talk.
What nonsense.
That's pretty good.
Is that so?
Mm-hmm.
Good one.
What nonsense.
I salute you.
Most impressive.
That's good.
Um...
You can't scare me.
That's pretty good.
Not now.
I salute you.
Most impressive.
I don't think I got it.
I see.
I don't think I got any further.
Be seeing you.
Oh, wait.
Go ahead, please.
I can ask her about Glarthur.
Well, I know he's a bit odd, but I've always thought he was kind of sweet.
Lately, though, he has been stranger than usual.
I think maybe he's been following me.
I see him every morning on my way to chapel.
I've tried to say hello, but he always pretends not to hear me.
Oh!
Be seeing you.
Riemann in the southwest of the city to train bulls.
Wait, but I talked to him, and he said he doesn't train anymore.
This great field is a great place to gather materials if you wish to level up alchemy.
I'm not so interested in alchemy, I think.
Well met.
Let's just, uh...
Wait, which gate was this?
Westgate?
Okay.
Let's...
Um, what time is it?
It's only 10 a.m.?
Holy... wow.
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
Hmm.
What's alchemy for?
Ah.
I don't know.
Wait, where am I?
Am I outside of town?
Oh, I...
I think I am.
I just...
I just left.
No, Glarther, wait!
Potion seller.
I require your finest potions.
Oh, I'm tired.
Can I have your horse?
What is it, citizen?
I would like to ask you a question.
Please talk to me.
Can I help you?
Okay, you could look at me.
He's that thief that the...
Wait, I didn't mean that.
Rumors.
If you've got to travel, by the Nine Divines, stay on the roads.
The wilderness just isn't safe anymore.
We've had sightings, you see.
The Daedra.
What's the Daedra?
What about the Nitra?
There's got to be a door somewhere around here.
Run!
Eat, Tina!
I've completely forgotten about the air.
We don't care about that guy anymore.
Oh, I'm back at the vineyards.
How the hell?
What is that horse doing?
He's trying to escape.
You can do it!
He looks like he's made of plastic.
See, if that were my horse.
He wouldn't ever be in such a...
precarious situation.
He's fine, probably.
Oh, here we go.
Wait, this is where I went before.
Oh, I think I just continued onward.
And that's how I left.
What?
What are you talking...
Come on.
Join the fighter's guild.
See the world.
And get paid for it.
You just said I'm hated.
Excuse me?
Okay, I'll join the fighter's guild.
If you're interested, see Valena, Daunton in Coral, or Azan in Anvil, or Burrs Grow Cash in Chaydenhall.
The whole West Weald is pretty good goblin hunting country.
Okay.
They're thick here in Colovia, along the Valenwood and elsewhere borders.
Yeah, I know you guys hate goblins.
Join the guild.
You won't regret it.
He hates me!
Oh my god.
Ew, it's scum!
How is this guy?
What are you doing here?
How do I get more famous?
Why can't you just do a favor for me, my friend?
What?
Oh, I'm just pulling at my heartstrings now.
The whole thing...
alchemical.
Okay.
That's our guy.
Do you think he'll...
Oh wait, that's not our guy.
I have pity on an old war veteran.
Oh, you...
I don't think you're telling the truth.
This is...
What am I...
Where am I?
I'm kind of lost.
Hi!
Is this the church?
Yes, this must be...
I think.
I think this is the church.
So that means...
Glarther is around here.
I'm just gonna wait until midnight.
We wait a whole...
11 hours.
With no interruption.
We'll be fine.
Got a question.
Any chance for a Virgil playthrough of DMC5?
Maybe.
It's not...
Entirely out of the question, but...
I think I want a break from DMC for now.
He said meet here by...
At 11...
Or at midnight, no?
Oh, here he is.
Maybe he's heading over there.
I shall be...
Not suspicious.
I just realized also I've been playing in third person mode.
Does that...
Does that bother you guys?
That it's not...
Like, first person?
Or do you guys not care?
Not really?
Yeah, I just realized I've been playing like this the whole time.
Blood Crust Cavern.
Hello.
You saw Bernadette Penelis.
Did you?
She was watching me and following me, wasn't she?
Uh...
What if...
Can I feed into his delusions?
Can I feed into them?
They made third person much better in the remaster.
Oh.
Feed the fire.
You're right.
Just as I thought.
Excellent work.
There will be a bonus in this for you.
Don't worry.
What about the reward?
Yeah.
Ah.
Of course.
The gold.
Here.
But there is someone else I need you to investigate.
Okay.
150.
What else do you want me to do?
Tutius Sextius.
Do you know him?
A quiet fellow.
Appears harmless enough.
But I've identified him as one of my key suspects.
He's a clever one.
No doubt about it.
Eyes in the back of his head.
Always seems to know when I'm watching.
But that's where you come in.
You should wait outside his house and see what he does when he's not watching me.
I'll meet you here tomorrow night to get your report.
Okay.
I always suspected she was watching me.
Thank you for finally confirming it.
I think Glarthur is going to burn the city down.
I think he's going to go on a massive murder rampage.
And kill everybody here.
He lives in a large house between the low gate and the east bridge.
Alone.
Suspicious.
Don't you think?
A guy can't live alone anymore.
Without it being suspicious?
Okay.
Wow, we're at 81.
He really likes me.
But I can't do anymore.
So wait, where was it?
He lives in a large house between the low gate and the east bridge.
And the east bridge.
Okay.
Suspicious.
Don't let Tutius Sextius catch you following him.
You don't have to say the full name.
He's much more dangerous than he looks.
Hmm.
Okay.
East.
We're headed west.
So we need to go the opposite way.
Hi there.
Hello.
Wait.
Is it...
East gate?
Or...
Right here?
What is this?
Is this the east gate?
East gate.
Almost.
Don't let...
Tootie Sexy.
Who?
Oh, I found his house!
Oh gosh.
Jump scare.
Summit missed a manor.
Wait.
Oh.
Missed lock.
Oh, it needs a key.
Oh, interesting.
Okay.
The guard house.
Did you find it?
Did I find it what?
What?
Visible when I say tootie is sexist?
12 midnight and all's well.
Hope it stays that way, ma'am.
Yep.
Me too.
You have something you want to tell me about that...
Oh, no, wait!
No, no, no, no.
Um...
Uh, never mind.
Suit yourself.
No, he's my...
Bye.
He's my buddy right now.
Uh, boy.
Bye-bye.
Yeah.
We're not...
We're not gonna tell you anything about him.
He's totally fine.
What's so funny about Tootie is sexist?
Sex...
Sextius.
Oh, good morning.
Go ahead, please.
That Danis Artelian is a little too full of himself.
Sure, he's the captain of the guard, but I'm not impressed.
Take care.
Bye-bye.
Not much of anything here.
I guess we gotta wake...
Uh, or wait for, uh...
Tootles to wake up.
And then we follow him.
The sexy toot.
Tootius...
Sex-dius.
Do you think he's, like, supposed to be the sexiest?
Oh, I'm stuck.
Let's see what's in here.
Rosethorn Hall needs a key.
Uh, let's just stand in the middle of the street again.
For long hours.
Let's stand in the middle of the street once again.
E.Tina does not know how to sleep.
For, I don't know.
Eight hours.
This...
Six hours.
Five hours.
Oh, no.
Seven hours.
Wait.
Six hours.
That would be 7 a.m.
No.
Five hours.
Because...
They probably all wake up at five, no?
She sleeps upright.
Actually, E.Tina is very...
You know...
Because she's an alien.
She sleeps...
Uh...
Who are you?
Good morning.
She gets her energy, her sleep through...
Um...
Uh...
Photosynthesis.
Me?
I'm...
Falano.
House...
Falano?
Halalo?
Uh-oh.
Wait.
You need...
You know about the Nurn route?
I don't know.
Never seen that sort of route before.
Head over to the Westweald Inn and talk to Cendarian.
He could identify it for you, I'm sure.
Okay.
I'm the only alchemist in Skinkrad.
Not much business here.
But I can't go back to Morrowind.
It's just like anywhere else in the Empire.
By the way...
Morrowind?
I've never heard of that before.
Do you happen to know what the fine is here in Cyrodiil for necrophilia?
Just asking.
Uh...
Is it the first offense?
Let's assume...
No.
Then it's at least 500 gold.
That's nothing compared to Morrowind.
Thanks.
I'm listening.
Nope, nope.
My bad.
Bye.
Bye-bye.
Do you think this guy's awake yet?
No.
Wait, I think he's awake.
He better be in here.
I think, uh...
Our lady is...
Um...
Perhaps...
How goes it?
Oh, I was expecting, like, the sexiest man.
You're new here.
Or you'd know me.
Tutius Sextius.
My people have lived in Skinkrad since the dawn.
Father and the Count were best of friends.
Uh, what do you think of Glarthor?
I'm sorry, but I don't think I know any Glarthor.
Wait, do you mean that strange wood elf that you see wandering around the city?
Yes, I've seen him, but never spoken to him.
He seems to be at the low gate every morning when I pass by my way to the castle.
Gives me the strangest looks, now that you mention it.
Uh-huh.
Almost like he hates me, although I have no idea why.
You don't even know who he is.
Wait, why?
Yes, the strange wood elf who haunts the low gate every morning.
You said he was Glarthor.
I'm afraid I know nothing else about the fellow.
Perhaps you should seek out a priest.
Perhaps a beggar.
Or guardsman.
You and I, we have nothing in common.
What could we possibly talk about?
I don't know.
Take care.
What is that horrible noise?
What is that?
Reinforced door.
It's a very easy lock.
Oh, okay, he's leaving.
Never mind.
Oh, it's Nimrut.
So it must be in his drawers or something.
Okay, he's leaving.
Oh, please leave.
Why is he looking at it?
He's looking directly at the camera.
Oh, you don't know I'm here?
He sees me.
He doesn't see E-T-9.
How am I supposed to follow?
I don't think I'm supposed to follow this guy.
I think that's really...
Oh, wait.
What time is it?
7 a.m.
Tidings.
Wee!
Tidings!
Kick this guy in the head.
What door did I just hear open?
Good morning.
When one door opens, another door closes.
I'm only asking for a single call in the world.
Hi-ya!
If I start punching a man in front of the guards, what do you think they'll do?
Oh, whoops.
What's in here?
A clay bowl.
My fists are up.
What do you think they'll do?
H-h-h-h-h-h H-h-h-h-h-h-h-h-h-h-h-h-h-h-h-h-h That might not be the case to give goods in the land of the people.
He once may have powerful wizards.
It could be a dangerous situation.
Goodbye.
How are you?
Oh?
Goodbye.
Do you think he's...
Um...
Do you want another bounty?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha.
I don't wanna go in there.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe it's outside.
Maybe it's outdoors.
Hello.
Oops.
Maybe it's like behind his house.
Wait, no, that's not possible.
Wait, I'm stuck.
There we go.
It's gotta, yeah, it's gotta be upstairs.
Yeah, there's no way it'd be outside.
Hail.
Hail, actually.
It's partly cloudy.
Let's see.
It should be in a pod.
Let's try again.
Pod it upstairs.
Maybe in here?
Maybe in his room?
You think he'll notice?
I wish he'd leave.
Sneak.
Oh, thank goodness.
Shut up.
You didn't hear anything.
I'm going back in.
Maybe he's got money.
He's got some fancy clothes.
That's what he's got.
Oh, I don't want to deal with this.
Sorry.
Why don't you keep your money in your room?
So many clothes.
Oh, hello.
What?
Why don't you like me?
All right.
I can persuade you.
He loves a boast.
Gracious.
What a hero.
So, yeah, okay.
Admire bad.
Of course.
Sorry.
I don't get it.
You've got a point.
Don't waste your flattery on me.
I salute you.
Most impressive.
I can't argue with that.
Don't try to manipulate me.
You think that's funny?
There are two types of oblivion players.
Those that pick...
Nerd and Root for the quest and those that pick it for the silence.
Right?
I see.
Yes.
Okay, I'll leave.
Goodbye.
I'm just trying to get through this quest.
Oh, wrong way.
Wait.
I can probably go through his stuff in here, right?
Wait, can I get...
This is also very easy.
Oh, whoops.
Oops.
I didn't mean to do that.
Stop.
Put your fist away.
To the basement!
Anybody down here?
Oh, he's got some fancy things.
He's got...
This is where he eats, I suppose.
Anything besides food?
Aw, come on.
I can't rob a guy of his...
I guess of his dishes, I could.
What's that hourglass for?
I could rob him of his plates.
His...
His dishware.
And sell it all.
Hmm.
It's not worth anything.
Oh my gosh, I thought I was poisoned for a second.
I was like, what...
Why is my vision like this?
Hahaha.
Nurn route to...
Lo-fi and nurn route to...
Oh.
Oh, hello.
Sorry.
I'm following him.
I'm your relief.
Good.
I'm hungry.
Are you gonna leave?
He was your relief.
Steal his skin.
It's hard to sell stolen stuff.
Really?
Okay.
Oh.
I'm supposed to be...
Oh, gosh.
I'm looking at the view.
I'm not even paying attention to the man I'm following.
There's a man there?
I didn't even notice.
No, I'm just taking in this awesome...
Look at...
Look...
Oh my gosh.
Everybody take a picture of...
Wait.
I think maybe this would be a better one.
The sun is...
You need to turn around, girl.
There you go.
Better lighting here.
Oh my gosh.
Say...
Hogwart!
Where'd he go?
He couldn't have gotten far.
Oh yeah, he didn't.
Hi-ya!
Good morning.
Mm-hmm.
Hi there.
Hello.
Good morning to you.
I'm just practicing...
My jumping jacks...
In the morning.
Everybody needs a good...
Uh...
Routine.
Guys...
I don't...
I think this quest is boring.
Greetings to you.
Guys, I think this quest is a little...
Uh...
Morning.
He's going to the castle.
You can just wait behind the church and lie.
Wait, really?
Okay, let's go to the church.
Uh...
I haven't forgotten about the main quest.
I'm just, uh...
I was just excited...
I was so excited to do another quest.
And...
Garthor is just such a...
Persuasive and interesting guy.
Oh, speak of the devil.
Just want you to see that I'm very busy.
Everyone's talking to me at once.
I told you not to speak to me in public.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
I have no idea what time it is.
Yeah, and he pays.
So true.
How are you doing?
I can eat for a day with a single coin.
Gray fox.
He's a fairy tale.
Imperial watch.
Pretends there is a thief king named the Gray Fox.
Who controls all the thieves in Cyridil.
Of course, it's all just made up to give them an excuse to keep us down.
Wait, you said that before.
Oh, it's still...
That's weird.
Have a coin.
Thank you, kind lady.
One gold removed from the player's inventory.
Yeah, that's from Garthor.
Blessings of our king upon you.
Alright, let's go to the church.
And we wait there until midnight.
Yeah, we did get the letter from Gray Fox.
It's a love letter.
Let's wait until...
Wait, how...
Uh...
Wait.
Eleven.
Twelve.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Nine.
Ten.
Oh, I'm so stupid.
Yeah.
Wait.
Eleven.
Yes.
Metal Gear lore goes all the way back, huh?
It does!
Thirteen hours.
Psst.
Garthor.
What is this one?
Psst.
Garthor.
Garthor, where are you?
What if...
When Frank Jaeger got smooshed in one, he got isekai-ed?
That's what I think.
Where is he?
Where's my pal?
Hello?
Are you in the...
Oh, there he is.
What if I pickpocket him?
He only has eleven gold on him!
Wait, what's the key he's got?
What's quicksave again?
F5?
Oh, hello.
Tell me what you learned about Tutius Sextius.
Uh, he is spying on you.
F5, thank you.
I was right all along!
You're doing excellent work, my friend.
Mm-hmm.
And my money?
Here you go, my friend.
Trust me, you've earned it.
There is one last person that needs looking into, though.
Okay, okay.
Yes.
200!
Do you know David Suralee?
David?
Yes, of the famous Suralee vineyards.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pillar of the community, etc.
Who would ever suspect him?
Perfect cover for the ringleader of the whole conspiracy.
He watches my house constantly.
You'll see.
He leaves his house early each morning.
Watch him and report back to me here at midnight as usual.
Make sure he doesn't notice you.
Okay.
Be careful.
David Suralee is the ringleader.
You must not let him catch you watching him.
Okay.
I got you.
Wait.
Now?
Hold on.
F5.
Quick save.
Oh, it is his key to his house.
Thanks for the payment, Garthor.
Okay.
Now...
Um...
I want to go talk to the guy, though.
Let's see.
I'm going to wait...
Like...
12 hours.
We'll go to the, uh...
We'll go to the...
Vineyard.
And we're going to ask him about...
About him.
So paranoid.
Didn't realize he should...
That...
He should be watching you.
Yeah, exactly.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh, who are you?
How can I help you?
Ah, you can't.
Wait.
Where's...
Which way is the vineyards again?
This way?
My athletics have increased to 30.
Let's go.
Hi there.
Hello.
Hoop.
Wait.
Wait, they're not talking about him.
Sure.
Good day.
Oh.
I'm only asking for a single coin.
Wait, what'd you do about him?
Make it quick.
What are you saying about...
What are you saying?
I enjoy the wines that Tamika makes at her vineyard.
And they're reasonably priced as well.
Yeah.
Okay.
Have a good day now.
Have pity on the old war victory.
Um.
Is it this one?
I can't.
This place is...
Oh, they all look the same.
Uh.
Which...
Surly Brothers House.
Okay.
So to the red.
We're at the west gate.
I can't remember which gate is the...
He's...
Surely he's not at his house anymore.
You know?
It must be this one.
Yeah.
Uh.
But I don't remember where the vineyards are.
I can't remember.
It's you.
Hi.
I'm back.
I know it's outside.
I guess I'll just leave.
Through one of the gates.
No time to talk.
West gate?
Oh.
Hup.
We're fine.
I just want to ask him.
Oh, who are you?
Afternoon.
Till...
Oh, you're Tillmo.
Um.
Her sheep are escaping!
Hello there.
Hello.
Is this him?
What?
No, you're Shamir.
Never mind.
Goodbye.
Is it this guy over here?
Our ankles aren't broken.
We're totally fine.
Wait.
What are you guys doing?
I don't think that's how that works.
Wait.
Um...
Uh...
David.
The V-Day.
Which one is...
You're not...
No, you're...
Yes.
Can you please train me?
No.
I'm listening.
Maybe if I make you like me more.
Okay.
You're like a joke.
You hate boasts.
You're full of it.
Uh...
You can't scare me.
Hold on.
I messed it up.
Wait.
Oh, gosh.
How nice.
That's really funny.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's really funny, right?
That's just talk.
Oh.
How nice.
Oh, that's great.
You're pathetic.
See, we're at 70 now.
Wait, what?
Don't say I'm pathetic.
Yes.
Now, train me.
No.
We'll be seeing you.
Okay, bye.
Hello.
I don't even see a Davide around here.
I just wanted to ask him about...
Good afternoon.
...about...
Garthur.
Garthur?
What's his name?
Can't remember.
Oh.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, no.
Don't do...
He's like, no.
I can't do it.
Garthur.
Garfield.
I don't see anyone else around here.
Hmm.
Oh, maybe over here?
No.
So foggy.
It's spooky.
Hmm.
There is nobody by this name.
Does not exist.
He does not exist.
Now he's making up...
People.
Not in here.
Okay, bye.
Hmm.
Is that the red quest marker?
That was his house, but I couldn't go inside.
Who are you?
I'm Tamika.
Oh.
We grow our own grapes and make fine wines.
Okay.
Tamika.
I need to head over to Colobian Traders and pick up a few things from Goonder.
He's got a nice selection.
I sold to him.
You might pick up my second-hand goods.
I've seen actually...
Here, it is perfect for grapes and perfect for wine.
I've seen only grapes, but no wine.
But the climate is milder.
And the rainfall more reliable.
Bye.
I guess we'll go to the...
He's doing a lot...
A lot of really good guarding.
He can buy it at the inn.
Oh.
I see.
Let's see.
Well met.
I'm running, running.
Running, running.
It was...
Huh?
Oh, over here.
Yeah, see?
I can't get in.
You know what?
Screw it.
I'm going back to the...
I'm just going to lie.
We're lying to him anyway.
What's another...
What's another lie?
What was that?
Who will help an old beggar?
The NPCs in this game are so funny.
Okay.
Now we wait.
It would be ten...
Nine hours.
Two.
One.
Bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing.
Glarthor.
Shh.
So, what did you discover about the upstanding Daveed Surly?
Oh, God.
This guy's about to murder everybody.
He is spying on you.
And so, it all falls into place.
Yes, yes.
It all makes sense now.
Here.
This is your last task.
What's that?
My reward?
Here's the gold.
As promised.
I always pay my debts.
And then some.
Do the last task.
In that note.
And I will pay you much, much more.
Did you guys see what the note was called?
List of death.
These people must be killed.
There's no choice.
They are definitely conspiring against me.
Bernadette Penelis.
Tutius Sextius.
Davide Surilly.
The ringleader.
Kill him first.
Come back and see me.
Make sure you are not followed.
Once it is done and I will give you your reward.
Blarthur.
I think...
I think we should go...
Report him.
I've been working for the feds.
I'm not loyal to anybody.
Guards!
But...
I could sneak into their homes in the middle of the night and murder them in their bed and nobody would know.
How goes it?
It pays a lot?
It does?
He did say...
How much is a lot?
We talking about a thousand?
A couple thousand?
Hold on.
If I quicksave and snitch on him...
Evening, ma'am.
Ma'am?
Urus the shepherd sure does take care of his sheep.
And boy, does he like cheese.
I mean, he really likes cheese.
I'll make a heart save, yeah.
He really likes cheese.
Farewell.
Yeah, let's make a heart save.
You're right.
I want to name it.
Okay.
Let's see what happens if I...
If I...
Ride him out.
You have something you want to tell me about that nutcase?
Yes!
Um...
He thinks there's a plot against him.
Really?
He's getting worse then.
Thanks for letting me know.
If you think he's becoming dangerous, you come straight to me.
He really likes cheese.
And I'll handle it.
He needs to be arrested.
I can show the note!
Okay.
I'm coming with.
I want to watch his face when it happens.
He's still here.
Oh, damn.
Mudcrabs more fearsome than you.
Oh.
Glarth.
Oh, he just leaves.
Damn.
That's it.
That's it for our guy.
Oh, Glarth.
Oh.
He died with a smile.
Come here.
Free house.
True.
I can take his clothes, too.
Oh, God.
Glarth.
Oh, never mind.
I don't want to see your...
I don't want to...
I don't want to see that.
What was yours?
This?
Oh, gosh.
Wait.
Put it back.
This one.
Oh.
I can't...
Sorry.
Let's go check out his house.
Just goes to show that snitching doesn't pay.
Literally.
He would have paid me money.
Now look at where we're at.
Opened with Glarthor's key.
Oh, just auto-saved.
That's so scary.
Could I say...
Should I say...
Home sweet home?
Mysticism.
What if they were really trying to plot against him, though?
What if I did do the right thing?
Or wait.
I mean...
What if...
What if killing them would have been the right thing?
That's what I meant to say.
Gosh.
Thanks for making me make the hard save.
Because if I had walked in here, it all would have been final.
Oh, I hate that.
I don't want that in my house.
Guide to Bruma.
Can't believe the feds got Glarthor.
Maybe he was right after all.
Oh, there's an upstairs.
One gold.
Two gold.
Three gold.
Four gold.
Five gold.
Eight gold.
Where was he getting all this money from?
Because...
I am not seeing it.
In his home.
Oh!
Very hard cupboard!
I'm never seeing...
I've never seen one...
Very hard before.
Gosh.
Actually, maybe I spoke too soon.
No
way.
I thought I had that one.
For real.
I did it!
Iron war axe.
Whoa.
This one too.
Oh.
Who stores a broom in a chest?
Yeah, right?
I misread it.
Oh.
Oh!
I...
Alright, that was my fault.
What the?
Ah!
Don't let the...
Slow pins fall all the way.
But don't I have to like...
Get it while it's at the very top?
No?
Maybe I don't understand...
How it actually works.
You can push a pin again as it falls.
Oh!
My
god!
That's what I thought was the slow one though!
This is...
I don't have...
I don't...
I'm gonna lose all my...
All my pins!
All my lock picks!
Six!
Oh.
No.
Get...
Take the money.
I like how I feel like I'm committing to this.
Even though...
I don't know.
I mean, it does have a nice place.
It'd be cool to live here.
Ugh.
I'm gonna try the hard one.
Wait.
Which one was the hard one?
Oh, here.
I want this one.
It's like...
I can't read it very well, obviously.
Cause...
I can't tell when it's gonna be so fast or not.
Ah, shit.
How could you tell?
Spam the pick when it looks slow.
Wait, what do you mean, spam the pick?
Like this?
How can I even read it though?
It all looks fast.
It all looks fast to me though.
Oh, like that.
Oh, I...
Oh!
Like that!
Oh my god.
Oh, man.
So close.
Oops.
Oh, okay.
Maybe hard is still too difficult for me.
Okay.
I should probably re-watch that video first.
Shut up!
Okay.
I can't tell what's like... Oh, oh.
Maybe this is the slowest one.
Oh!
Okay.
Huh.
No.
Oh, there we go.
I feel like it makes it more difficult, but at the same time, I guess easier.
I don't know how to describe it.
Because I'm like, you have to time it exactly with the click, you know?
Oh, ow, ow!
I pressed the wrong button.
I've played Oblivion for almost a thousand hours and never lockpicked like that.
I guess I just really like this mini game since it's never bothered me.
It's not bothering me.
I'm just still learning how to do it.
Oops.
Okay.
Maybe that one.
You can get a skeleton key and I'm breaking lockpick from a shrine.
Oh.
This is the stream now.
Seeing what's in his big chest.
And then I'll reload.
One, two, three, go!
It's a piece of meat, his prized meat, you think?
I can't!
Beep bop beep bop beep bop!
Oh, just two more.
This is why alteration magic is superior.
I don't even know what that is.
So, if you're trying to offend me, I am ignorant to your offense.
On feet, I don't think I am just a little bit late.
Three, two, one, go.
Maybe if I go from the other side, it'll feel a little...
It'll feel, you know...
Three, two, one, pick.
That one guard that's been watching you try and pick this lock for...
What do you mean, the one guard?
Nobody's watching me.
Inside, there's like a camera.
Actually, inside, I open it up and there's the guard.
Oh,
I hope... Oh gosh, you guys, I feel like I'm gonna fumble this.
Careful, SpongeBob!
The pressure!
Oh my god, it's like when you're trying to defuse a bomb and they're just like, okay, don't cut the green wire.
And all you hear is green wire.
First try!
Oh, it's just a bunch of weapons.
I picked it, though.
Yes, sir-y, I did.
And with that, you guys, I'm gonna call it a night.
Next stream, we will kill the other people.
In the middle of the night.
I'll kill them, and I'll collect my riches.
And then we'll be on our merry way.
Um, to...
Uh, get my horse back.
Get my horse!
And also...
Um...
Also...
Oh, the...
The death guild.
Hard save?
I already did.
Or, yeah, hard saved earlier.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
Get to you!
Thank you so much for the 20 gift.
Thank you.
Hmm.
Yes.
Well, thank you, guys, for a stream.
This was fine.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Thank you!
And...
I have no stream tomorrow.
Um, but...
I...
The day after, we'll be more oblivion.
So...
We'll...
We'll just pick up where we...
Left off.
Pick another chest.
No, it's okay.
Because we're not even keeping this save.
I picked that...
I picked this chest just to see if I could do it.
Hahaha.
Just because I wanted to say that I could.
But...
We're not keeping this save.
We're, uh...
We're doing this...
Oh, no.
This is the autosave.
We're doing...
This...
This one.
Hahaha.
We're doing this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This one.
This is the one that...
We didn't...
We're not gonna snitch to him and we're gonna...
Catch...
We're gonna...
Get our...
We're gonna murder the three people and then get our reward.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that's what we'll do.
Save three, exactly.
Save number three, Skingrad.
Skingrad.
Yes.
So, thank you, guys, for the stream.
And I will see you, guys, when I see you next.
And, yeah, thank you, guys.
Thank you, guys.
Bye-bye.
See you guys later.
Baby, bye-bye.